Hallo, hallo
Wer ist da so alles am Start? Schon der Feuja ist wieder da. Ah, du bist aber auch immer schneller am Start
Der Stream ist 20 Sekunden on
Und du warst vor 20 Sekunden, du warst instant da. Ich glaube immer noch, dass du irgendeinen Bot hast für sowas
So schnell kann es doch gar nicht sein normalerweise
Chatgy, Pfeil fährt Chatgy
Wie lange war ich das letzte Mal eigentlich on? Schon ein bisschen her, oder?
War ich denn das letzte Mal on?
Vor fünf Tagen, guck mal, so lange ist das schon her
Mich ein 50 Spiel Jahren auch am Start
Nee, gar nicht mal so sehr
Auch abends immer mal so ein bisschen, aber nicht, aber nicht so krass, ja
Ja, bei mir ist es auch übelst warm
Aber ich habe ja den Glück, ich habe eine Klimaanlage. Wilder Igel, dankeschön für den Sub
Ich habe zum Glück eine Klimaanlage
Lor-Sum-Alpha
Dankeschön für den Sub. Ja, Klimaanlage ist ein gutes Stichwort. Ich werde mal die Klimaanlage anmachen
Deine Klimaanlage läuft den ganzen Tag durch. Naja, das ist ja auch nicht so schlimm
Wenn du es nicht zu kalt eingestellt hast, kühlt die ja nicht unbedingt permanent und verbraucht mega viel Strom
Es ist wahrscheinlich sogar besser, wie man stellt die zu kalt ein und dann macht man zwischendurch immer wieder aus und dann wieder runter
Die regeln das eigentlich ganz gut. Ich hatte jetzt auch zwei Stunden oder so die Klimaanlage laufen
Habe jetzt eine halbe Stunde wieder aus, aber ich bin halt blöd, ich habe die Tür zum Flur hin aufgelassen. Das heißt, es ist wieder alles warm
Aber ich muss mal, ich schaue mal kurz, Moment, lass mich mal kurz gucken
Home Assistant Arbeitszimmer
Im Serverraum ist es nicht so schlimm, aber es ist ein bisschen kühler
Im Serverraum ist 30 Grad, Leute
30,2 Grad im Serverraum
Ordentlich. Naja gut, ich meine, hey, es ist nicht nur im professionellen Rechenzentrum, der Rechenzentren der Trend
Dass man es ein bisschen wärmer werden lässt im Vergleich zu früher. Warum nicht auch bei mir im Kabuff?
Ja, hier bei mir im Zimmer ist es ja so zwischen 26 und 27 Grad. Ich war blöd und habe das nicht eingestellt, dass ich das
Hinterm Komma sehe. Ich denke mal so 26,8 oder irgendwie sowas, weil vorhin war es 27,4, als ich die Klimaanlage angeschmissen habe
Also ich muss echt sagen, das hat sich wirklich gelohnt mit der Klimaanlage
Ich habe die Klimaanlage vor
Das war vor Corona noch
Also sprich, ja, ich denke mal so fünf Jahre müsste ich die wahrscheinlich sogar schon haben
Ich habe da, ich habe dazu garantiert damals was auf Twitter geschrieben, aber
Twitter ist ja nicht mehr richtig durchsuchbar. Twitter ist ja nicht mehr benutzbar. Richtig gescheit
Ich habe übrigens auch gelesen
Dass Twitter jetzt irgendwie den Blockbutton oder so entfernen möchte. Das wird sicherlich ganz viele Leute abfacken
Die instant irgendwie immer alle Leute blocken. Ich habe nicht so viele Leute geblockt auf Twitter, muss ich sagen. Vielleicht
Vielleicht über die ganzen Jahre, lass es mal 20 Leute sein oder so. Wirklich nicht viel insgesamt. Also muss es mir schon echt auf den Sack gehen auf Twitter, dass ich Leute blocke
Es gibt ja Leute, die haben so... Kennt ihr das?
Das finde ich ein mega bescheuerter Trend, den es auch schon so ein paar Jahre gibt. Es gibt so Bubble-Blocklisten
Also wenn du jetzt irgendwie denkst, ich bin der krasse
Was weiß ich
Woke-Typ oder so
Und dann kannst du quasi
Dir irgendeine
Blocklist suchen und
Da sind dann Leute drauf, die von anderen, die so deine
Gesinnung und Meinung teilen, gemeldet haben und da kannst du quasi instant irgendwie 3000 Leute blocken
Obwohl du gar nicht weißt, wer das ist und was
Total wir. Also es gibt Leute, die blocken halb Twitter gefühlt per automatischer Blockliste
Keine Ahnung, was da abgeht. Ja, das habe ich gelesen, das habe ich gelesen, aber
Ganz ehrlich, ich bin da mittlerweile vorsichtig geworden
Ich dachte am Anfang auch
Dass einige Änderungen so auf Twitter gar nicht mal so blöd gewesen sind
Aber die letzten paar Wochen kamen Sachen, die ich fast
Durch die ich Twitter fast als kaum noch richtig benutze. Ich habe auch gar nicht mehr richtig Bock, Twitter zu benutzen
Kaum als richtig benutzbar. Also der Loginswagen ist mega für den Arsch
Ja, man kann wohl, wenn man auf Tweets referenziert, was ja viele Newsseiten machen
Ja und die Umbenennung in den X finde ich auch hängen geblieben
Tweets verlinkt auf Newsseiten geht, da sieht man aber keine
Antworten mehr und sowas
Also Loginswagen ist bescheuert und es ist, es ist, es ist einiges
Auch dass die Suche nicht mehr funktioniert gescheit und wenn du nicht eingeloggt noch wo drauf gehst
Wenn es überhaupt geht, dann ist es nicht sortiert und sowas
Ganz, ganz furchtbar merkwürdig. Vielleicht die Umbenennung in den X finde ich auch ultra bescheuert
Also ich, ja, zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel das mit den Haken und so
Dass das jetzt ein System ist, was irgendwie nachvollziehbar ist
Dass du nicht wie früher auf gut dünken, wenn irgendeiner von Twitter der Meinung ist
Du bist prominent genug, dass du einen Haken kriegst, kriegst einen Haken
Dass es irgendwie so eine halbwegs nachvollziehbare System ist jetzt
Ich finde es prinzipiell gar nicht so verkehrt
Aber die letzten paar Änderungen auf Twitter finde ich bescheuert
Deswegen bin ich jetzt auch vorsichtig geworden, ob da nicht doch solche Sachen hier durchgesetzt werden
So nach dem Motto, wir entfernen die Funktion
Ja, sie können die Funktion vielleicht nicht entfernen
Weil die Funktion von App Store Regeln sowohl bei Apple als auch bei Google vorgeschrieben ist
Aber sie können sicherlich irgendwelche anderen Sachen machen, um das aufzuweichen
Und im Endeffekt, wenn sie Twitter komplett gegen die Wand fahren wollen
Was immer mehr, ich habe es ja am Anfang nicht geglaubt, dass das der Fall sein könnte
Immer mehr so aussieht, dann scheißen sie drauf, wird es halt aus dem App Store geschmissen und weiter
Dann ist es halt dead
TweetDeck habe ich früher benutzt, schon ganz lang her
Irgendwann war das, das war damals glaube ich sogar noch eine Flash-Anwendung
Oder nee, nee, nicht Flash
Leute, wie hieß diese Geschichte von Adobe? Das war nicht Flash
Sondern, wie hieß dieses App Store?
Sondern, wie hieß dieses Application?
Air, ja, ja, das meine ich, aber wir haben es schon ganz vergessen
Ja, Adobe Air war das TweetDeck früher
Und seit der Umstellung und seitdem das nicht mehr so gescheit lief, wie das damals
Ich habe das eine ganze Weile benutzt, benutze ich das auch nicht mehr
War ein wirklich cooles Tool damals
Seitdem benutze ich bloß noch die offizielle Twitter App
Und im Endeffekt sonst nix, halt die Webseite und die App
Ja, ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, das trifft nur wirklich wenige
Ich habe was gelesen mit, du musst wie viel? 15 Millionen Impressionen haben
Also ich habe mal durchgeguckt
Ich glaube, in Monaten, wo ich viel hochgeladen habe, also generell überall aktiv war
Viel Leute drauf waren
Und ich auch sehr viel auf Twitter gepostet habe
Und auch wirklich ganz recht erfolgreiche Posts dabei gewesen sind
Hatte ich, glaube ich, wenn es hochkam als 2,5 Millionen Impressionen
Wenn es hochkam
Jetzt aktuell natürlich deutlich weniger
Ich kann das vergessen, damit was zu verdienen
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, ich twittere auch nicht, um damit Geld zu verdienen
Also, keine Ahnung
Also, das Problem ist
Das Problem ist ja auch nicht so sehr, dass Twitter suckt
Sondern, dass ich mich frage, ob es irgendwelche Alternativen geben wird
Die weniger sucken
Die nicht irgendwelche anderen No-Go-Sachen dabei haben, auf die ich gar keinen Bock habe
Und die vor allem die Masse der Leute benutzt
Das ist ja das Ding
Sowohl bei Twitter, bei Facebook, bei Instagram
Bei allem, was Social ist
Früher bei ICQ, dann bei AOL Messenger
MSN Messenger, Skype
Egal was du nimmst, diese ganzen Social-Kommunikation-Tools
Network-Tools
Die funktionieren ja nur
Wenn andere Leute, guckt euch WhatsApp an und sonst was, guckt mal
Wie lange gibt es WhatsApp-Alternativen?
Wie lange gibt es schon Telegram und Signal und sowas?
Signal hat sich nie großartig durchgesetzt
Für die meisten Leute, aber für das, was es halt machen soll, ganz gut
Telegram hat sich noch so am meisten durchgesetzt
Aber ganz ehrlich, WhatsApp ist immer noch das Größte
Und wird es wahrscheinlich auch mit riesigem Abstand bleiben
Letztendlich ist es ein sehr wichtiger Faktor bei diesen ganzen Social-Dingern
Wie viele Leute drauf sind
Deswegen wird sich Masterdon auch nicht so richtig durchsetzen
Mag ja alles ganz schön und gut sein
Aber was bringt es dir, wenn halt niemand da ist?
Ja, eins habe ich hier schon gelernt im Chat
Eins habe ich schon gelernt im Chat hier
Wir sind nicht sonderlich repräsentativ für die Allgemeinheit, was technische Tools angeht
Ich meine, wir haben ja sogar Leute, die verwenden E-Macs, Alter
Kann man sich kaum ausmalen
Also sind wir wirklich nicht repräsentativ für die allgemeine Technik
Für die allgemeine Zustand der Leute
Übrigens, zum Thema E-Macs
Letztens auf der Arbeit
War ich in einem Call, wo ein Dienstleister dabei war
Und da zeigte er auf einmal ein paar Konfigs
Und was macht er auf? E-Macs!
E-Macs, da dachte ich mir mal
Ich glaube, das letzte Mal E-Macs habe ich vor acht Jahren oder so gesehen
Bei mir selbst
Ich kann dazu nichts Qualifiziertes sagen, weil ich verwende weder WhatsApp noch Telegramm
Also keine Ahnung
Wir benutzen hier auch alle Arch, hoffe ich mal
Und wir gerade dabei sind, wir machen mal kurz ein Package-Update
Signal verwenden auf der Arbeit
Also Signal ist das Einzige, wo ich mal ein bisschen so rumgeguckt habe
Was sie machen
Und denen ich glaube, dass es quasi klein-seitig verschlüsselt
Und nicht abhörbar ist
Ne, das meine ich gar nicht
Sorry, nicht Signal
Threema meinte ich, nicht Signal
Vergiss es, ich habe das verwechselt
Threema benutzt keiner
Ich habe mir ein paar Jahre hingekauft
Den ich das abgekauft habe, dass die wirklich klein-seitig verschlüsseln
Ohne, dass es irgendjemand mitlesen kann
Verwendet das überhaupt noch irgendjemand?
Oder Threema, oder wie man das ausspricht
Ich glaube, das hat nie jemand
Ich habe das gerade verwechselt
Es gibt ja WhatsApp, Telegramm, Signal
Die sind ja alle drei relativ groß, wobei WhatsApp mit Abstand der Größte
Und ich gefolgt von Telegramm, glaube ich
Ich wusste gar nicht mehr, dass das was kostet
Naja, zumindest
Es ist halt das gleiche Ding
Du brauchst für diese ganzen Social Sachen immer eine gewisse Verbreitung
Und das hat halt aktuell
In dem Segment nur Twitter
Also mal gucken, mal gucken was Facebook
Und mal ganz im Ernst
So sehr die Leute das irgendwie feiern mit Threads
Und so von Instagram, beziehungsweise Facebook
Ich bin mir nicht sicher
Ob ich lieber einen Service vom Zug verwenden will
Als einen Service vom Elon
Irgendwie gibt sich das glaube ich nichts
Und selbst, ja ich weiß, die Leute sagen jetzt
Ja, aber mit Threads kannst du ja Mastadon und alles mögliche anbinden
Ganz ehrlich, das machen die so lange
Wie das für sie von Vorteil ist
Und danach wird der Support immer weiter zurückgebaut
Und die User absaugen erstmal
Die easy zu haben sind
Und dann wird das immer weiter reduziert
Und inkompatibel gemacht, so Microsoft Taktik
Und irgendwann klappt es nicht mehr richtig
X Defiant spielen, das habe ich sogar schon mal installiert
Und bei Ubisoft
In diesem scheiß Ubisoft Launcher
Aber ich habe es bis jetzt noch nicht gespielt
Ist gerade wieder
Ist gerade wieder irgendein Beta Wochenende
Oder ist das mittlerweile raus, ich habe das überhaupt nicht mehr verfolgt
Wirst du Starfield spielen? Ich weiß nicht genau
Keine Ahnung, ich war nie der große Fallout Fan
Und keine Ahnung
Weiß ich nicht
Es gibt ja noch viele Games, die ich erstmal spielen muss
Wollte zum Beispiel schon seit Release
Dieses, ich habe schon wieder vergessen wie es heißt
Atomic oder so hieß das doch, hieß es nicht Atomic?
Russische Bioshock
Spielen
Ich habe mir das gekauft, zu Release installiert
Aber nie gespielt, hieß das nicht Atomic?
Russisches Bioshock
Atomic
Atomic Hard
Ja das meinte ich
Genialer Hintergrund, du meinst den hier?
Der ist Porc ne?
Wenn du den selbst, du kannst diesen Hintergrund übrigens selbst benutzen
Und zwar
Du gehst bei mir auf GitHub
WhitePepoHappyDesktop
Und hier hast du alle
Für jede Tageszeit
Hast du einen
Guck sogar den Workout Pepo
Und wenn du Lilums benutzt, kannst du auch irgendeines von den beiden Skripts
Verwenden zum automatischen Background setzen
Ihr werdet sehen, alle 10 Minuten
Ändert er sich und immer der Tageszeit
Das ist ja auch der, das ist ja quasi der
Windows XP Hintergrund, nur noch etwas
Weiter weg vom Original
So haben wir jetzt eigentlich alles geupdatet
Ich hab gar nicht geguckt, ich glaub schon
Reboot
Ja das ist nice, Factorio fand ich auch
Mega Pog
Factorio ist auch so ein Spiel, das kann man
Theoretisch Jahrzehnte spielen
Gerade mit den ganzen Mods dabei
Das kannst du täglich Jahrzehnte spielen fast
Wenn du dich da komplett
Wenn du da komplett drinnen abgehst
Alle 10 Minuten
Ne das kommen auch schon ab und zu mal die gleichen Hintergründe
Ich hab's einfach
Angestellt, dass sich das alle 10 Minuten ändert
Der Tageszeit
Entsprechend
Es kann auch sein, dass die Bilder doppelt kommen
So viel Bilder sind es, ich glaub es sind
Aktuell, keine Ahnung 20, 25
Bilder oder sowas
Ja
Pepo Sonnenuntergang
White Pepo Happy
Also White
Nicht White, sonst kommen die Leute wieder
Pepo
Nicht, dass der Pepo noch ein weißer alter Mann ist
Das wollen wir ja nicht
Weißer alter Frosch
So jetzt können wir die VM wieder ausmachen
Ja
Wobei, das ist ohne Scheiß
Wahrscheinlich ist dafür
Das einzig Gute daran, wenn
Twitter untergeht
Die Leute können nicht mal ganz so
Krass Circle Jerken auf irgendwas
Wundert
Mich nicht
Es ist ein naheliegender
Naheliegendes
Emote dann
White Pepo Happy
Ich hab wieder die Hälfte vergessen
Vorzulesen glaube ich
Creator Dashboard
Zoa hat subscribed gestern
Warum zum
Warum zum Teufel
Followt mir die Marmeladen
Oma
The fuck
Ich hab die mal vor 3 Jahren oder so gehostet
Hä
Das ist eine Oma
Die liest immer irgendwelche Märchen und Geschichten
Vor
Die hab ich mal gehostet vor 3 Jahren oder so
Hast du schon mal überlegt
Einen Keks Vtube Avatar zu machen
Ja hab ich
Tatsächlich hab ich das schon überlegt
Aber es ist unglaublich schwierig
Irgendjemanden zu finden
Der fähig ist
Sowas zu erstellen
Ich hab schon
Ich glaub in Zeit bin ich danach am gucken
Ob irgendjemand
Ich find keinen der das
Gescheit hinkriegt
Der sagt ja ich kann sowas
Bleibt mir eigentlich nur noch irgendwelche Leute
Bei Pfeiffer zu bezahlen wo ich nicht
Gescheit weiß was da rauskommt
Es wird natürlich ein bisschen teurer werden
Weil es schon ganz schön viel Arbeitsaufwand bedeutet
Also wenn das ordentlich gemodelt ist
Und wie heißt das geriggt
Wenn das so mit virtuellen Knochen
Versorgt wird
Das macht ja nix
Das kann ja ruhig ein bisschen was kosten
Aber es muss halt auch was Gescheites bei rauskommen
Ey Leute ich verdien nicht
Letztens hat mich auf der Arbeit jemand doch gefragt
Tatsächlich
Was kann man mit Youtube so verdienen
Hab ich auch gemeint man kann mit Youtube enorm viel
Verdienen aber ich verdien nicht viel mit Youtube
Dazu müsste ich halt mal
Ein bisschen mehr hochladen und ein bisschen mehr Sellout
Machen und alles ein bisschen mehr
Content Creator
Mäßig 2023
Aber ihr kennt mich bin ich viel zu faul
Ja das weiß ich
Es gibt ein paar die können so
2D Anime Style Avatare machen
Oder 3D
Ich fände einen 2D Keks
Tatsächlich deutlich passender als
Einen 3D Keks
Aber für die meisten Leute ist es deutlich einfacher
Einen Avatar zu machen der menschlich aussieht
Als ein
Ja etwas abstrakten
Keks Avatar
Du verdienst aktuell mehr mit Twitch oder
Ach so pauschal kann man
Das nicht sagen also
Wenn das ein Monat ist also
Nicht unbedingt also hier
Wenn man sich das auf Youtube
Anguckt ja die letzten 2
Also wenn man jetzt mal diesen Monat hier
Nimmt ja da gab es quasi
Hier es gab 3 Videos
Und die sind alle recht gut angekommen
Dann kann das schon mal mehr sein
Aber
In der Regel ist es mit Twitch
Mehr ja
Ja selten
Also ich meine
Wir werden wahrscheinlich immer ab und zu mal irgendwie
Ein bisschen was schreiben wir kannten uns ja auch schon
Vor Youtube und allem möglichen
Aber jetzt in letzter Zeit ist es relativ wenig
Weil es gibt halt nichts was man groß zusammen spielen kann
Und ich weiß auch ehrlich gesagt
Gar nicht was der gerade macht
Der macht ja laufend irgendwas anderes
Wann war der zuletzt on
War der irgendwann mal zuletzt on
Dachte eigentlich
Der wollte ein bisschen Diablo 4 streamen
Hat er glaube ich auch
Aber nicht irgendwie
Einmal oder so
Ja das ist keine schlechte Seite
Weil es Gate 3 kam
Ich weiß nicht ob der Fabian auf sowas steht
Eigentlich dachte ich
Dragon Age Origins
Fand der mega damals
War ja auch ein richtig gutes Game
Und ich glaube von
Ohne Mist von den ganzen RPGs
Kommt glaube ich
Baldur's Gate 3 am ehesten
In diese Richtung
Wie Dragon Age
Origins
Ich finde die beiden Games sind sich doch ziemlich ähnlich
Also mal davon abgesehen
Das es halt reines
Rundenbasiertes Ding ist
Aber so vom Style
Von der Kamera
Von der Grafik
Ich finde Dragon Age Origins und Baldur's Gate 3
Ist sich da doch recht
Von den Quests
Ist doch schon ein bisschen ähnlich
Aber keine Ahnung
Ob der Baldur's Gate 3 spielt
Oh schon lange nichts mehr gehört
Oh doch hab ich
Ich hab letztens mein Handy auf
Do not disturb
Und da hab ich letztens reingeguckt
Hab gesehen er hat mich versucht anzurufen vor 2 Wochen
Oder so
Ich hab das irgendwie erst wieder 5 Tage später gesehen
Und ihr kennt mich
So Social Dinger
Er ist auch doof
Dann sag mal lieber nichts
Aber er ist das der einzige
Auf Youtube mit dem ich wirklich gut verstanden hab
So die Jahre wo wir da aktiv waren
Kann ich echt nichts schlechter sagen
Das liegt
Ihr kennt mich
So soziale Sachen mit Leuten telefonieren und so
Neue Battlefields
Echt wann ist es denn soweit
Wann ist es denn soweit
7. Juni
Ja gut das sind ja noch 3 Wochen oder 4 Wochen
Ja 3 Wochen
Ok ja das gucken wir uns mal wieder an
Da bin ich gespannt
Ob es noch mehr Kisten gibt
Das gibt es
Das existiert glaube ich nirgends wo mehr
Nutzt du ein OCR System
Für Paperless Dokumente
Ehrlich gesagt nehm ich nicht
Ich scan manche Sachen ein
Das ist aber ganz simpel ich hab einen Drucker
Der kann entweder auf den Netzwerk Share pushen
Oder auf den USB Stick
Aber der macht da kein OCR
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher bin ich glaube
Das das sogar teilweise ein bisschen geht damit
Aber wahrscheinlich nicht gut
Und ansonsten hab ich ne
Etage im Schrank
Da sind ein paar Fächer drin
Und da pfeffer ich einfach alles rein
Und
Scan das dann ein
Und schick es einmal im Jahr an den Steuerberater fertig
7. Juni
New Dawn
Das haben wir doch gespielt oder haben wir New Dawn gespielt
Alter was ist das für eine ästhliche Seite
Season 6
Der Jura
Danke für den Sub
Season 6 Release Date
Im Oktober
Wie jetzt
Im August
Ja wann denn jetzt
Die wissen es nicht
Hehe geil
Ok die Games sind einfach
Kein Bock alles klar
Es kommt erstmal eine
Mini Season
Achja ja dann haben wir das gespielt
Mit der Schneekarte
Das kenn ich das haben wir gespielt
Hast du eigentlich von dem
Update für früher COD
Hab ich mitgekriegt aber
War es nicht ein Problem auf dem PC
Die alten Call of Duty Teile zu spielen
Weil die Leute dich ganz einfach mit
Irgendwelchen Viren
Infizieren können
Durch irgendwelche
Buffer Overflows
Im Call of Duty Client
Gab es da nicht gravierende
Sicherheitslücken bei alten Call of Duty Teilen
Aber war was
Ich hab da immer einen großen Bogen drum gemacht
Ja
Ja Leute
Morgen früh wieder aufwachen streamen
Wir können uns noch ein paar Videos angucken
Was haben wir denn hier zu
Oh guck mal was ist das
PHP does not suck
Anymore
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher
Ob ich das glauben soll
Was sagt
Also ich hab PHP ausprobiert
Vor ein paar Wochen
Und ich war der
Meinung dass
Danach das PHP
Eigentlich immer noch suckt
Das Video ist nicht er
Aber PHP suckt
Vielleicht PHP nicht mal selbst
Aber das Ökosystem und so das hat mir
Überhaupt nicht gefallen
Ich weiß jetzt kommen gleich wieder die Leute um die Ecke
Max wann gibt es endlich den Rust Rewrite
Es wird Zeit Leute
Haha Max muss Rust Rewrite machen
Nein ich muss keinen Rust Rewrite machen
Vorher mach ich eher
Einen C++ Rewrite
Bevor ich den Rust Rewrite mache
Ist auch so ein Ding
Unter Windows was mir mega auf den Sack geht
Warum
By the way
By the way Leute
Warum kann man diese
Ich suche im Internet Option
Nicht abschalten
Das geht nicht
Hier
Man kann nur
Content filtern
Ich will gar kein Internet Search
Bei mir haben
So ein Kack
Immer noch da
Welttag der Fotografie
Was ist eigentlich daran so schlimm
Naja also 2 Sachen
Schaut mal auf so
Pauschalen die mir anfallen
Erstens es geht mir auf den Sack
Hä Moment
Ist es jetzt weg
Äh Hä
Okay
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen ist es jetzt weg
Ähm ja und das zweite Problem ist
Dass meine Suchanfragen im Zweifelsfall
Zu Microsoft geschickt werden
Ach bei Rust
Wieso an Rust ist nichts Schlimmes
Ich hab aber keinen Bock die Sachen in Rust
Zu Rewriten
Weil es macht keinen Sinn was was zu funktioniert
Zu Rewriten einfach nur
Rust Rewrited werden kann
Wie gesagt
Das sieht die Rust Task Force
Auf Hacker News
Sicherlich anders
Aber es gibt ja auch auf Github
Rust Rewrite
Die Hälfte
Die Hälfte der Rust Projekte
Auf Github
Ist ein
Ich habe Rewrited in Rust
Aber Placing Default guckt euch das an
Ja
Guck mal ich mein
LS
LS wird Rewrited in Rust
Und
Ich hab auch mal ne Weile Exa verwendet
Hab ich das überhaupt noch
Ne hab ich nicht mehr
Aber ich seh einfach
Keinen Sinn drin
Warum nicht einfach LS
LS ist perfectly fine
Nekorok Dankeschön für den Sub
Es gibt
Zig solcher Tools
Das ist das mit den
Icons
Das kenn ich doch gar nicht
Das ist schon
Abandoned seit 2 Jahren
Das ist übrigens auch ein Grund
Solange es nichts in diesen neuen Tools gibt
Was so viel besser ist
Bei den alten Tools bleibe
LS wird halt einfach nicht duplicated
LS wird es halt immer geben
AM wurde Rewrited
Warum wurde
AM Rewrited
Damit ja damit LS
Ein Prozent
Aber man muss halt ehrlich sagen LS
Es ist jetzt nicht so als hätte das in irgendeiner Art und Weise
Guck mal das ist nicht
Hier okay
Ja nice
Es hat 4 Millisekunden gedauert
Ich glaube das muss eindeutig Blazingly fast
gemacht werden
Das ist wichtig
Ich glaube 4 Millisekunden sind schon
Problematisch interaktiv auf der Shell
Ich glaube da kann ich nicht
Mit leben das muss in Rust
Rewrited werden
Compare mal zu der Rust Variante
Okay das machen wir jetzt
Achtung
Ich hab doch extra sogar noch installiert
So
Also compare mir mal
Das mit dem okay
So Time
4 Millisekunden
Versus
3 Millisekunden okay
5 Millisekunden
Also 4 Millisekunden
Versus 3 bis 5 Millisekunden
Beides
Ich mein man kann das bestimmt
Warte mal man kann das wahrscheinlich
User
Bin time-v
Wie heißt denn das
Ähm
Time
Es gibt ja ein
Besseres Time Tool
So
Okay nice
So das hat gebraucht wie lange jetzt
Okay das war so schnell
Das ist
Sekunden hat das nicht gebraucht
Millisekunden gibt es nicht
Also ganz ehrlich ich merke da keinen
Unterschied man müsste
Vielleicht mal ein etwas längeres Verzeichnis
Machen
Das probieren wir jetzt aus
Ich mach jetzt ein Verzeichnis
Temp
Touch
Wie viele Dateien machen wir
Ich will meine vm nicht überlasten
10.000 Dateien 100.000 Dateien
So
Okay jetzt braucht es ein bisschen länger
Blazingly fast
Time
437 Millisekunden
Ah guck mal
Der Rust Rewrite ist langsamer
Ich kann euch auch sagen warum der
Rust Rewrite langsamer ist das ist ganz offensichtlich
Der Rust Rewrite ist wegen mehr
Farben langsamer
Mehr Farben bedeuten
Mehr Text Output
Man musste Color ausstellen
Color kann man sowas hier machen
Color gleich off oder so
Ne
Never
Ah trotzdem
Trotzdem
Guck mal
LS ist einfach schneller als der Rust Rewrite
Also warum soll ich den Rust Rewrite
Verwenden
Wegen Blazingly fast
Exposed
Nein
Auf gar keinen Fall
Aber was ist denn der Sinn dann zu Rewriten
In Rust wenn das Original
Noch Blazingly faster ist
Ich verstehe das bei manchen Tools wie
GitHub zum Beispiel
Wenn Leute dann irgendwie
Das Linux Kernel Verzeichnis durchgreppen wollen
Weniger Crashes
Klar
LS Crasht auch so oft
Chat hattet ihr einmal
Jemals einen Crash
Von LS
Ich weiß gar nicht ob LS überhaupt Crashen kann
Git
Ja
Das kann ich mir schon vorstellen
Ich find es mit Farben schöner
Also ich hab
Tatsächlich ne Weile extra verwendet
Weil ich das auch cooler fand
Dass man hier das richtig erkennt
Aber ich muss sagen
Ich komme
Mit
Der Sache hier mittlerweile mit LS
Irgendwie angenehmer
Klar es ist überall drauf
Du hast dich an die Optionen gewöhnt
Extra unterstützt auch nicht 1 zu 1 alles wie LS
Dann Terminal Rewrite
In Rust mein Terminal ist in Rust programmiert
Das hier
Das ist ein Rust Based Terminal
Ihr guckt
Rust
Rust basiertes Terminal
Also ich hatte jetzt quasi ein
Rust LS
In einem Rust Terminal
Also viel schneller kann es
Viel Placingly Faster wird es ja nicht mehr
Das ist Placingly
Fast
Und trotzdem ist der Standard LS
Schneller
Er hat sich aus Placingly Faster
Zumindest als LS Alternative
Wollen wir uns das PHP Video angucken
Wir gucken uns jetzt gleich das PHP Video an
Chatge
Und irgendjemand bei euch am Start
Von denen die letztens geschrieben haben
Ich krieg das leider nicht mal aus dem Kopf zusammen
Wer das alles gewesen ist
Die Bewerbung geschickt haben
Gibt es bei euch irgendwas Neues
Wurdet ihr genommen wie war das Vorstellungsgespräch
Wie war
Wie war es so falls irgendjemand von denen da ist
Es hat in letzter Zeit recht häufig
Jemand was geschrieben in der Richtung
Es haben sich auch schon ein paar zurück gemeldet
Aber könnte ja sein dass es neue Storys gibt
Du hast zwei Verträge vorliegen
Ich hoffe beides
Big Stonks Money
Ich hab Montag und Dienstag Teammeetings
So kennenlernen
Erstes
Mal so gucken wie die Leute so drauf sind
Meeting oder wie
Hab ich nur einmal
Einmal gemacht
Zweimal hab ich das gemacht
Zwei Stunden
Die wollen es aber wissen
Also
Okay sag mal ich hab das einmal gemacht
In letzter Zeit
Und
Das war glaube ich 45 Minuten
Da hab ich sie etwas verwirrt
Du kannst den Teams ja so blocken
Dass die Leute in das Meeting können
Bevor nicht irgendjemand in dem Meeting drin ist
Und die Leute zulässt
Wer auf dem Handy kennt kann diese Beschränkung nicht
Und joint auch geblockten Meetings
Und da war ich schon in dem Meeting
Und hab in die Kamera gewunken
Da kam erst die Frau von der Personalabteilung rein
Und hat sich gedacht
Huch warum bist du schon hier
Ich hab das Meeting noch gar nicht gestartet
Nick Diet
Dankeschön für den Sub
Gibt es ja keine neuen Azubis
Ganz ehrlich was ist die Alternative zu Teams
Zoom oder wie
Ganz ehrlich
Ich finde Teams ist zwar
Sehr bloated mittlerweile
Und jetzt auch nicht die schnellste Anwendung
Ich verwende es übrigens auch
Nur im Browser
Aber
Die Alternativen die ich da bisher gesehen hab
Skype for Business kennt das noch jemand
Hatte jemand von euch mal die Ehre
Skype for Business verwenden zu müssen
Das ist richtiger Schrott
Zoom musste ich letztens
Mit einem Dienstleister in einen
Zoom Call
Hat mich auch nicht gerade begeistert
Ja aber Slack kann sicherlich bei weitem nicht alles
An Kommunikation was Teams kann
Ich weiß es nicht weil ich Slack
So
Nicht benutzt habe in dem Umfang wie Teams
Aber Teams hat ja
So viele Vielfalt
Mittlerweile
An Telefonanlagen anbinden und sowas
Okay Webex fand ich auch immer abartig
Webex noch schlimmer
Teams frisst halt ohne Ende RAM
Aber
Also Webex ist
Leute ich musste mal wo wir gerade
Wo wir gerade bei komischen Videokonferenz
System sind
Es gab ja mal eine Zeit
Da gab es noch Videokonferenzanlagen
Da ist man dann wenn man mit Leuten an einem anderen Standort
Reden wollte in den Videokonferenz
Raum gegangen
Und ich musste mal eine Videokonferenz
Anlage aufbauen von
Handberg
Hieß das glaube ich
Nein die wurden von Cisco gekauft
Anscheinend mittlerweile
Das
Sah gar nicht mal so
Unähnlich aus dazu
Unähnlich aus
Ja so in der Richtung
Ja so sah das
Aber noch älter noch älter
Aber so in der Richtung sah das aus
Und das Ding war jedes
Mal kaputt und hat Probleme
Gemacht bei jeder
Videokonferenz hat irgendwas nicht
Funktioniert das war so schlecht
Und das hat irgendwie
10.000 Euro oder sowas gekostet so ein Ding
Das war so kacke
Das war schon das richtige Meme damals
Bei uns auf der Arbeit
Das war noch ist schon lange her
Da war ich noch beim Internet Provider damals
Das war schon so das Meme bei uns
Und was das Handberg Ding wieder
Als nächstes für Probleme hat
Das liegt aber wahrscheinlich an euch und nicht an
Microsoft
Bei solchen komischen Policies und
Sachen vielleicht muss bei euch erst einer
Das das
Bild abnehmen oder sowas
Das wird wahrscheinlich nicht an Microsoft liegen
Oder vielleicht liegt es auch an deinem Browser Cache
Weißt du schon
Barco Screensharing was ist das
Barco ist für mich eine App
Mit der man
IOS
Ist das nicht so
Mit der man
Barcodes einlesen kann
Ah ne Barco
Hieß das
Ja die meine ich
Barcodes scannen
Das ist wahrscheinlich auch der
Größte Vorteil wenn man eben auf dieses
Microsoft Ökosystem steht
Dann passt halt Teams ganz gut rein
Ich meine ich mache einen großen Bogen drum
Es ist so ein Ding bei uns auf der Arbeit
Also in meinem Team
Da gibt es ein paar Leute
Bestimmt 80% des Teams
Die stehen unglaublich
Auf OneNote
Und ich kriege jedes Mal
Komplette Anfälle wenn ich OneNote benutzen muss
Ich benutze das einfach nicht
Ich schreibe halt manchmal ein paar Sachen rein
Wenn es nicht anders geht
Aber ich habe einfach
Textfiles die ich durchcappen kann fertig
Ohne Mist
Dann würde ich ja sogar lieber ins Confluence
Schreiben wusstet ihr das OneNote
Keine Substring Suche kann
Du findest in OneNote nichts
Also mal angenommen du hast jetzt in OneNote
Du hast so ein Befehl
curlkeckel.com
slash
blub123
So und du weißt
Du weißt das
Das in diesem Befehl irgendwie blub
Gleich drinne vorkommt ja
Und du suchst blub gleich in OneNote das geht nicht
Blub findet nur curl oder keckel in dem Fall
Die Suche
Funktioniert nur an Wortgrenzen
In OneNote
Mega mega beschissen ist das
Mega Müll
Vielleicht kann man das in den Settings irgendwie umstellen
Dass das eben dann nicht vom Index
Sondern direkt zur Suche
Zur Linearity drüberscann
Suche wechselt
Aber mega beschissen OneNote ist komplett unbrauchbar
Für mich
Ist es im Browser jetzt besser was denn
Du meinst Teams
Denn wenn du Linux verwendest
Bleibt dir nichts anderes übrig als den Browser zu verwenden
Und ich benutze es aber auch unter Windows
Im Browser
Eigentlich auch einfach weil ich es zusätzlich installiert haben muss
Ja Confluence haben wir auch
Die haben eh dort wo ich aktuell arbeite
Die haben eh 30
Milliarden Systeme alles doppelt und
Dreifache
Das ganz alte OneNote
Habe ich auch mal ne Weile verwendet
Ich glaube nicht dass es Confluence
Nur als Cloudlösung gibt
Es gibt Confluence Datacenter und Confluence
Cloud ich glaube Datacenter gibt es auch
Weiter zum selbst installieren
Chat Geek
Kennt sich jemand mit Atlassian Shit aus
Ja Obsidian würde ich tatsächlich auch benutzen
Also privat
Wenn es eine Sache hätte
Die es leider nicht hat
Und zwar
Dass du Termine eintragen kannst
Die auch mobile funktionieren
Active
Inspire das kenne ich nicht
Das hört sich an wie irgendein Spell aus dem MMO
Active Inspire
Active Inspire Unterrichts Software
Oh je
Das klingt Pains Champ
Von Lehrenden für Lehren
Was
Alter
Kann man nicht einfach Schüler schreiben
Das geht mir so auf den Sack teilweise
Ich habe hier nichts dagegen wenn Leute das gerne
Machen und das untereinander so verwenden
Oder so aber es ist teilweise einfach
Beschissen zu verstehen man
Ich muss mir das mal angucken was machen die dann
Dann nenn es irgendwie
Anders dann nenn es Schüler
Studenten was auch immer
Von Lehrenden
Für Lehrende
Was zum ich kann den Satz noch nicht mal aussprechen
Von Lehrenden
Für Lehrende
Entwickelt
Ich verstehe nicht was das mir sagen soll
Das ist quasi von Lehrenden
Für Lehrer wollen die damit sagen oder wie
Von Lehrenden
Für Lehrer
Man schreibt halt von Lehrer für Lehrer
Meine Güte
Alter
Ich handhabs ja normalerweise so soll jeder machen was er will
Aber in dem Fall
Die wollen ja was verkaufen das hätte schon seinen
Vorteil wenn man es auf den ersten Blick versteht
Selbstverständlich können sie machen was sie wollen
Aber ich habe es halt nicht gecheckt
Media Wiki ist auch ganz nice
Ich persönlich mag Doku
Wiki eigentlich immer noch leider
Hat Doku Wiki halt immer noch
Diese blöde Doku Wiki
Wenn man Markdown gewöhnt ist
Doku Wiki
Das richtig coole an Doku Wiki ist
Das alles Plain Text ist
An Daten
So okay was
Euer Lehrer verwendet
Moment
Active Inspire
Was haben die denn so
Classflow
Active Inspire
Jeder Unterricht wird zu einem
Echten Erlebnis
Ja aber bestimmt nicht wegen
Active Inspire
Muss man in Offenbach an die Schule
Da ist sicherlich jeder Unterricht zum Erlebnis
Wenn dann einer das Messer rausholt oder sowas
Ganz selbstverständlich
Digital unterrichten
Okay ganz ehrlich das sieht natürlich
Cool aus
Wenn das dann alles so funktioniert
Moment
Moment hat der da Paint auf im Hintergrund
Ist das Paint
Das ist nicht so richtig
Touch friendly oder
Nee das ist nicht Paint
Das ist sowas ähnliches
Das ist die Software
Aber ganz schön klein oder
Ich mein guck mal wie dick der Finger von ihm ist
Da triffst du ja die Farbe noch nicht mal richtig
10 großartige Vorteile
Ich glaub mein Darkreader macht es kaputt
Von Active Inspire
Verwenden sie den virtuellen Würfel
Im Mathematik Unterricht
Das ist doch eher ein Glücksrad oder
Alter das ist gar kein Würfel
Ändern sie den Drehpunkt eines
Bliebigen Objekts
Noch nie da gewesen
Wahrscheinlich ist das
Wieder so ein Tool was ganz gut ist
Wenn die Lehrer damit umgehen können
Ich will jetzt nichts schlechtes über die sagen
Weil ich kenne die Software nicht
Es könnte nämlich auch sein
Ich weiß nicht wer es hier geschrieben hat
Ich mein sowas muss ja pauschal nicht schlecht sein
Wie gesagt sie können auch einfach
Schreiben von Lehrern für Lehrer
Oder was ich persönlich noch besser
Finde von Lehrkörpern
Für Lehrkörper
Wie man nicht genau
Sicher bin wie man die schreibt mit EH
Oder mit 2E
Die haben massive Probleme mit Treibern
Wie kann man massive Probleme mit Treibern haben
Bei der selbst hergestellten
Hardware Software Kombination
Das Programm unterstützt keinen
Touch du musst das Board so einstellen
Das es die Maus als Finger
What?
Du meinst das es den Finger als Maus erkennt oder?
Weil wenn es keinen Touch
Unterstützt muss es ja nicht den Finger
Was genau machst du auf damit?
Irgendeine interessante Story aus dem aktuellen Sprint
Digga ob es irgendwas Spannendes
Gibt was Sinn macht zu erzählen
Wo ich ein bisschen
Anonymisieren
Ich weiß nicht fällt mir jetzt grad nichts ein
Hört mir jetzt grad nichts ein
Wir schlagen uns mit schlechter
Software vom Hersteller
Also mit schlecht verpacketierter
Software von einem Hersteller rum
Die schaffen es jedes Mal
Leute die haben es letztens geschafft
Wir haben eine Software gekauft
Von einem Hersteller
Ich sag euch jetzt nicht welche
Und die ist dafür ausgelegt in einem
Kubernetes
Wie auch immer Cluster zu lauen
Und
Die liefern dann offiziell das Helmchart mit
Das ist quasi Setup
Exe für Kubernetes
So könnt ihr euch das vorstellen
Und die haben es geschafft bisher
Bei jedem Release irgendwas grundlegendes kaputt zu machen
Pass mal auf
Ich zeig euch mal ein kleines Beispiel
Was die geschafft haben beim letzten Release
Kaputt zu machen und zwar
Die haben Images
Im Kubernetes Manifest so geschrieben
Hier Image
Keine Ahnung
Registry.max
Slash Image
Slash 1.0.0
So Chatge
Wer ist HighAQ Docker Registry
Kubernetes Kenner? Was ist daran falsch?
Es ist eigentlich offensichtlich wenn man das öfters sieht
Die Version ist falsch
Richtig
Hier muss ein Doppelpunkt sein anstatt ein Slash
Korrekt
Und ich hab ein Upgrade gemacht
Von
1.9.0
Auf 1.9.1
War das glaube ich
Ich hab ein Upgrade gemacht und auf einmal
Geht nichts mehr
Weil alle Images nicht mehr pullen
Weil sie ein Slash
Hier hingeschrieben haben in ihrem Template
Anstatt ein Doppelpunkt
Und das sind so Dinger wo ich mich halt frage
Wie kann das passieren?
Jeder
Egal wie minimalistisch
Ob es funktioniert was man gemacht hat
Sollte diesen Fehler abfangen
Weil das Image wird falsch getemplatet
Das heißt egal was man macht es startet nie
Es kann nie das Image pullen
Weil das einfach syntaktisch falsch ist
Dass ein Slash an der Stelle ist
Also keine Ahnung was sie da treiben
Und die machen halt öfters so Zeug
Also Chat
Wenn ich eine so universal Weisheit
In der IT gelernt hab die letzten
15 Jahre über
Wenn eine Software kompliziert
Zu installieren ist
Also sodass man sich da wirklich
Die ganze Tage mit beschäftigen muss
Bis man verstanden hat
Bis man es proof of concept mäßig installiert bekommt
Dann ist die Software es meistens nicht wert
Benutzt zu werden
SAP Consultants werden mir jetzt widersprechen
Weil die verdienen mit dem Scheiß ihr Geld
Aber wenn eine Software kompliziert
Zu installieren ist
Sodass es nicht möglich ist die innerhalb von
Minuten bis ein paar Stunden
Da eine Demo hinzustellen
Ist es meistens nicht wert zu benutzen
Das heißt nicht dass eine Software
Schwierig
Installiert
Das heißt nicht dass eine Software
Nicht schwierig installieren zu sein
Kann mit allen Optionen
Aber die Minimalkonfiguration
In einem
Wir wollen es uns einfach mal angucken
Guckt euch zum Beispiel GitLab an
GitLab ist der Abfuck extrem zu installieren
Aber du kriegst es doch
Relativ simpel
In einem kleinen Demo Modus zum Laufen
Mit Docker
GitLab ausgebaut ist
Der Abfuck komplett
Macht ihr denn wirklich Scrum nach
Lehrplan
Naja
Nachdem es keine offizielle
Kein offizielles einzig gültiges
How to gibt wie man Scrum
Macht
Würde ich sagen wir machen Scrum doch
Relativ
Relativ dementsprechend
Was man sich darunter vorstellen würde
Mit Daily Absprachen
Mit Sprintplanung
Mit Retrospektive was man besser machen kann
Mit Plan für das nächste Mal
Mit Review was gelaufen ist
So mit kleinen Vorstellungen
Kleinen immer Abschnitten
Was man vorstellen kann
Wir machen das glaube ich ziemlich
Lehrbuchmäßig
Natürlich insgesamt
Ist halt immer die Frage ob man es wirklich
Ganz so extrem zelebrieren muss
Ich denke ja die beste
Agile Methodik ist die
Die im jeweiligen Unternehmen gut funktioniert
Ob die jetzt wirklich aus dem Lehrbuch ist
Oder anhand dessen was irgendein
Consultant da mal oder Scrum
Coach die gecoacht hat ist doch
Wurscht ja aber so wie die das machen
Funktioniert das ganz gut
Es ist nicht übertrieben
Es ist alle zwei Wochen Dienstag
Ist das übertrieben weil alle zwei Wochen Dienstag
Das war übrigens die
Diese
Diese Woche war das
Da war wieder
Ich mache Dienstag alle zwei Wochen
Nichts wirklich gar nichts
Ich gehe
Auf die Arbeit
Und ab 9.30 Uhr
Geht es los mit
Daily und Retrospektive
Und Review
Und Planning und das ganze geht offiziell
Bis 16.30 Uhr oder gar 17 Uhr
Aber ich
Hau immer 16.00 Uhr 16.05 Uhr ab
Das wissen die auch alle schon
16.05 Uhr bin ich weg
Apple TV iPad
Ich denke es ist tatsächlich ganz sinnvoll
Bei solchen Sachen
Ein bisschen die Lehre mit einzubeziehen
Was ihr
Präferiertes System ist
Also dementsprechend müssen die
Ein bisschen was ausprobieren es hat nämlich meistens
Keinen Sinn wenn man Lösungen und Techniken
Und Software und Hardware und generell
IT Lösungen einführt
So komplett 90
So 180 Grad entgegen
Dem was die Leute sich wünschen
Oder was die gerne hätten
Das klappt meistens nicht
Dann wird es auch meistens nicht richtig benutzt
Hast du Tipps um deine Ausbildungsvergütung
Hoch zu handeln
Ganz ehrlich ne
Aber mach dir mal nicht
So viel Gedanken um deine Ausbildungsvergütung
Das hält ja nicht so lang
Mach dir lieber Gedanken darum
Wie du danach ordentlich Kohle bekommst
Du musst nämlich
Nicht zwangsläufig da bleiben
Also hör dich da ruhig
Schon mal frühzeitig um
Was du sonst noch für Optionen hast
Anstatt dort zu bleiben wo du deine Ausbildung machst
Dann hast du nämlich
Eine ganz andere Verhandlungsbasis am Ende der Ausbildung
So Ausbildungsvergütung
Hochhandeln
Ich gehe mal von aus
Die wenigsten Unternehmen werden das machen
Die haben wahrscheinlich
Ich weiß gar nicht ob es Tarifverträge für sowas gibt
Aber es ist ein festgelegtes Ding
Was jeder Azubi kriegt
Und es ist jetzt ja auch nicht
Als könntest du irgendwie großartig
Da
Als hättest du irgendwie
Druckmittel
Beziehungsweise als hättest du irgendwie was
Du kannst sagen ja
Wenn ich nicht mehr Geld kriege dann hau ich ab
Juckt uns doch nicht
Also insofern
Ich glaube da würde ich mir nicht so viele Gedanken zu machen
Guck lieber dass du danach ordentlich was rausgehandelt kriegst
Ich meine sicherlich kann man
Fragen kostet nichts
Und denen gute Argumente bringen
Was für ein geiler Azubi du bist sicherlich auch
Aber ich glaube ehrlich gesagt nicht
Dass sich da viel tun wird
Danach hast du eine deutlich bessere Verhandlungsbasis
Wenn du dich ein bisschen umgeguckt hast
Also benutzt lieber die Zeit jetzt
Wenn du sagen wir mal
Ein Dreivierteljahr oder so
Für Ende der Ausbildung bist
Guck dich ruhig schon mal um
Wenn du ungefähr weißt was bei euch in der Region
Beziehungsweise in der Branche da angesagt ist
Und was du noch für Optionen hast
Kann man das nicht in den Values setzen
Doch kannst du
Du kannst das überschreiben das funktioniert
Aber du willst ja nicht jede einzelne Imageversion
Das Ding besteht aus was weiß ich
15 verschiedenen Images
Willst du denn alle überschreiben
Also sowas muss out of the box funktionieren
Bist du eigentlich anerkannt der IHK Ausbilder
Ne bin ich nicht
Ja hab ich gemacht
Aber ich war nie anerkannt
Also ich bin kein anerkannter IHK Ausbilder
Ich muss demnächst IHK Ausbilderprüfung machen
Echt was muss man da so machen
Was kommt denn da so dran
Ist die Ausbilderprüfung schwer
Ist die AE
Ausbildung
Warum kürzen wir jeden Kack ab
Wir haben einen Scrum Master
Der war jetzt aber 3 Wochen im Urlaub
Ich glaube der ist nächste Woche wieder da
Eigentlich würde man dann sagen
Geht das ja gar nicht
Du kannst ja keinen Scrum machen ohne Scrum Master
Und doch das funktioniert
Wenn die Leute nicht vorhaben
sich abzufacken
funktioniert das
Es muss einfach passen zu dem was man macht
Es hat keinen Sinn
Agil zu sein
Nur um nach irgendeinem gewissen Schema agil zu sein
Sondern es muss ja unterm Strich auch was bringen
Und auch passen
Wie viel bekommst du denn
Also
Ist das
Ich meine als Azubi musst du eh nicht so viel Steuern bezahlen
Also wahrscheinlich ist das was du insgesamt
Brutto bekommst wahrscheinlich nicht so viel höher
Ja das ist natürlich schon
Nicht viel
Also ich hab letztens irgendwo gesehen
Bei der Telekom oder so
Da hab ich irgendeinen Azubi gesehen im dritten Jahr
Hat auch glaub ich hier jemand geschrieben
Der bekommt 1400 Euro oder sowas
Ausbildungsvergütung
Das ist schon wirklich wenig
Also ich glaube ich hab auch nicht so viel mehr bekommen damals
Muss ich sagen
Allerdings war das halt 2007
Ich hab dann am Ende auch
Irgendwie was weiß ich 1000 Euro oder so gekriegt
Ahja ist schon ein bisschen her
Aha
Das heißt es gibt dann Prüfungs Azubis
Ich hab meine
Ausbildung nicht verkürzt Leute
Wisst ihr was der Grund ist warum ich meine Ausbildung nicht verkürzt hab
Jetzt geht mal in euch
Ihr kennt mich
Warum hab ich meine Ausbildung nicht verkürzt
Dreimal dürft ihr raten
Ja so siehts aus
Ich hatte keinen Bock
Ich hab mir gedacht ey
Soll ich jetzt ein halbes Jahr oder ein Jahr
Wenn ich verkürze
Warum soll ich verkürzen
Ich kann jetzt noch ein Jahr hier abgammeln
Berufsschule ist für einen Arsch
Musst nichts für machen
Auf der Arbeit musst du auch nichts machen
Wenn ich gerade
Ich konnte einfach noch
Ein Jahr mehr abgammeln
Warum hätte ich das nicht machen sollen
Das würde ich aber nur im äußersten Notfall
Machen wenn der Rest ganz gut ist
Würde ich die Ausbildung
Versuchen durchzuhalten und dann halt woanders hin
Die sind dann bestimmt danach auch
Knauserig deswegen ist wichtig
Dass du noch während der Ausbildung guckst was du für Optionen hast
Ich mein wie gesagt
Fragen
Kostet nichts aber
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen weil
Ich kann mir auch so wenig kriegen
Aber
Ich werd dich nicht rausschmeißen
Wenn du ihn fragst
Mal ganz davon abgesehen
Einer der riesen Vorteile als Azubi ist
Du kannst Azubis nicht rausschmeißen
Es sei denn
Die klauen
Die klauen Hardware oder so
Moin Chainlore
Hast du die Webseite?
Nein noch lange nicht
Wir haben da insgesamt vielleicht
4-5 Stunden dran gearbeitet
Das ist vielleicht zur Hälfte fertig
Wie lange hast du denn noch
Chili irgendwas mit
Chili Bambili
Wie lange hast du noch
Ausbildung
Jetzt im 2. Jahr
Dann hast du es doch fast hinter dir
Jetzt im 2. Jahr heißt
Ah jetzt im 2. Jahr
Das heißt das 2. Jahr hat jetzt angefangen
Gerade erst oder wie ist das
Weil meistens ist das ja so in dem Dreh hier
Ja gut hast du
Hast du im Endeffekt erst 1 Jahr rum
Gut vielleicht kannst du ja verkürzen
Aber ich würde
Auf jeden Fall die Zeit nutzen
Knowhow aufzubauen
Was einem später Kohle bringt
Weil wenn du keine Ahnung hast nur weil du Physi bist
Bringt es dir das auch nicht
Die Ausbildung ist nicht das was dir
Letztendlich den Job bringt
Sondern das was du gelernt hast
Beziehungsweise
Du musst es dir nicht mal in der Ausbildung erinnern
Was du halt weißt zu dem Zeitpunkt
Und am besten halt irgendwas
Was auch halbwegs
Beliebt ist
Also zum Beispiel Kobol-Entwickler
Am besten was was dir gefällt
Ohne Scheiß ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen
Am besten ist was ihr kennt euch
In dem Gebiet aus das euch gefällt
Das euch Spaß macht
Und wenn das auch immer besser dann fällt euch lernen nicht so schwer
Und ihr habt eine höhere Chance
Darin zu arbeiten und noch besser zu werden
Also es ist wirklich sehr sinnvoll
Sich
Auf was zu konzentrieren was einem gefällt
Ich weiß nicht
Können wir machen
Ich hab 7TV
Emote Slots gibt es ja tausende
Sinnvolle Zertifikate
Im Kubernetes Umfeld weiß ich nicht
Also auf Reddit
Im Kubernetes Subreddit
Sind gefühlt die Hälfte der Fragen
Wie man sein
Frag mich nicht wie das heißt
Kubernetes Certified Ding macht
Ich bin mir nicht sicher
Ob das so sinnig ist
Ob man das unbedingt braucht
Also ich mache aktuell auch zu 90%
Nur Kubernetes und Google Cloud Geschichten
Und ich hab kein Zertifikat
Und krieg trotzdem Geld dafür
Also insofern
Das hatten wir heute schon
Da warst du noch nicht da Chainlor
Bevor es den Rust Rewrite gibt
Gibt es den C++ Rewrite
Oh doch Leute ich kann euch noch was zeigen
Wisst ihr was ich
Wisst ihr was ich vorhin
Oder was heißt vorhin
Was ich letztens gelernt habe
Und zwar
Wir schreiben jetzt mal etwas Pseudo
C++
Nur 2 Zeilen
Macht euch keine Sorgen
Touch
Mainpunkt
Ich hoffe das geht so
Ich will euch mal was fragen
Was ihr denkt
Yes I trust the author
Ich truste den
Dockern
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich standardmäßig
Ja install die C++ Extension
Beste
Proprietäre Microsoft Shit
So also
Passt mal auf
So
Was meint ihr
Vor
So
Auto
Vector C++
Standard
Äh
Warum ist da nichts drin
Habe ich
Irgendwas vergessen
Ah ne ich muss das ja noch
Includen
Include
Vector
Ging das so
So passt mal auf
Ähm
Ja keine Ahnung
Äh das ist falsch was ich mache
Falsch
Was meint
MonkaS
Was meint ihr
Welcher Typ I ist
Jetzt
Also
Was meint ihr
Welcher Datentyp
Welcher Datentyp I ist
Ist das ein int
Ist das ein bool
Man würde vermuten
Das geht oder
Man würde
Also man würde eigentlich
Vermuten das geht jetzt
Ähm
Machen wir mal
Passt mal auf
Push
True
So und
Wie macht man das jetzt
Wie macht man eine ordentliche Ausgabe in C++
Ähm Standard
Format
Ne ach du Scheiße
C++ aus dem Kopf
Ne Cout ist
Das Noob Zeug das verwendet keiner mehr
Die machen doch
Standard
Standard Print machen die doch jetzt
Gibt doch neu
Macht doch keiner mehr
Cout
Oder doch
Ist egal
Ich versuch das mal zu kompilieren
Mal gucken ob das überhaupt funktioniert
Jetzt ist natürlich die große Preisfrage
GCC
Ich hab keine Ahnung
GCC Compile File
Keine Ahnung wie das überhaupt funktioniert aus dem Kopf
Oder ne G++ ist es oder
G++
G++ Compile File
Da muss man sagen irgendwie in
Ich tu nicht so ich weiß es einfach nicht
Wer weiß denn so was aus dem Kopf
So äh
Main CPP
Achso ja gut ich muss das wahrscheinlich ausgeben
Moment
Include
Stream muss man
Oder Stream
Ist das nicht Stream das man dann was ausgeben kann
Oh fucking hell
Ich will einfach was ausgeben
Iostream
C++ Standard Alt
Okay
Standard
Value
Value so und jetzt
War mal noch hier
Ein Newline okay
Funktioniert das jetzt
Okay es hat kompiliert und
Es funktioniert
Tja
Es ist ne Eins
Warum ist das ne Eins
Weil True
Also es ist jetzt was anderes
Als ich erwartet habe ehrlich gesagt
Aber
Worauf ich eigentlich raus will ich hab eigentlich gedacht es gibt
Ein Compiler Fehler aber gibt es nicht
Ähm
Also worauf ich
Worauf ich raus will ist folgendes
Wir könnten wir
Probieren das mal anders aus
Vielleicht ist der Iterator einfach so schlau
Okay das müsste auch
Funktionieren oder
Chatge
Ah Compiler
Ne Moment nicht Value Vector
Okay das funktioniert
Das ist ein Eins
Ich muss das jetzt mal testen weil vielleicht
Ist es in GCC auch gar
Nicht mehr so wie ich das denke
Tatsächlich
Das funktioniert
Okay
Ja, Moment, was ist denn das jetzt eigentlich?
Was, was ist denn das jetzt eigentlich für ein...
Es ist ein... Es ist kein Buhl, was da rauskommt.
Ja, das ist auch schon mal sehr merkwürdig.
Und?
Geht Add an der Stelle?
Scheint alles zu funktionieren.
Also, anscheinend, anscheinend hat sich das ein bisschen geändert zu dem, was ich heute gelesen hab.
Zumindest, den Artikel, den ich darüber gelesen hab, ist, dass außer StandardBuhl,
sich alle Vektor, Generic, mit was auch immer du da reinstöpseln kannst,
Normalverhalten, aber StandardBuhl Vektor eine eigene Klasse ist,
die keine Buhls in den Vektor schreibt, sondern aus Performance- und Platzgründen optimiert,
das auf einen Int mappt, auf die einzelnen Bits von einem Int.
Was sicherlich eine coole Sache ist, aber blöd ist Standard Vektor zu nennen,
wenn man doch, wenn man sich doch anders verhält, wie alle anderen Typen da drinnen.
Guck, man sieht hier auch, man sieht hier auch die, die ganzen Einträge von...
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie da was dran geändert haben.
Nachdem, also, als ich den Artikel gelesen hab, war ich mir eigentlich relativ sicher,
dass ein Index darauf nicht gehen dürfte, wobei man halt ja auch hier sieht,
es kommt ja da auch gar kein Buhl raus, so wirklich, ja.
Also, könnte ich denn jetzt, könnte ich denn jetzt überhaupt sowas sagen,
wie Value gleich gleich zu, wir machen das so, ich weiß, man muss das so nicht schreiben,
aber ich will mal ausprobieren, ob das, ob das funktioniert.
Ob der jetzt, nee, das kompiliert, okay, das ist, das funktioniert, ja.
Das, ja gut, aber C, bei C gibt es ja gar keinen Buhl im eigentlichen Sinne, ne.
Also, du kannst da noch eine Eins reinstecken, das ist auch okay.
Aber es ist ein Standard Vektor Buhl Reference Value.
Sehr, weird Champ alles, ähm, interessant.
Siehste, entweder habe ich den Artikel nicht ganz verstanden,
oder, oder die haben es mittlerweile ein bisschen, bisschen besser gemacht.
Was macht dein Auto in C++?
Normalerweise würde ich sagen, so wie war in C Sharp,
aber nachdem es C++ ist, bin ich mir nicht wirklich sicher, ob das der Fall ist.
Weil, du kannst in C++ auch sowas hier machen, was ich super, super mega weird finde.
Du kannst ein Auto Return Type haben.
Okay, bei Main funktioniert das anscheinend nicht.
Aber du kannst Auto Return Types haben, warum kann Main kein Auto Return Type haben?
Egal, ich will das gar nicht verstehen müssen.
Wir lassen es, wir lassen es jetzt einfach gut sein.
Ich will, ich will es gar nicht, gar nicht verstehen.
Naja, gut.
Dann, dann war der Effekt jetzt leider nicht so gut, wie ich mir das gedacht hab.
Ich hab gedacht, ich kann euch jetzt zeigen.
An der Stelle, guckt mal, da denkt ihr, es kommt ein Buhl raus und es kommt kein Buhl.
Es kommt ja auch kein Buhl raus und das geht nicht.
Auto Return sollte eigentlich nicht gehen.
Doch, oder?
Das ist deutsch, das geht doch, ja.
Auto Return C++, doch, doch, das funktioniert.
Guck da.
Ganz, ganz offiziell geht das.
Oder, oder geht das nur in einem Template?
Wobei, was hat das Template mit meinem...
Aber das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Warum kann ich nicht einfach A hinschreiben oder B?
Moment, was ist das denn jetzt schon wieder?
Was ist Standard Buhl Alpha?
Was zum...
What?
Also, es gibt immer C++-Typen und so.
Wo ich noch nie was von gehört hab.
Wo war ich denn jetzt hier eben drinne?
Hier. Ach, Repos, Temp C++.
Hä? Da kommt jetzt nix raus?
Buhl, was?
Muss man da jetzt, muss man da jetzt Value reinstecken, oder was?
Nee, keine Ahnung.
Ich, ich will's nicht verstehen.
Mir wurscht.
Out, outdated, overrated, too bad.
Kein C++ mehr jetzt.
So, dann lasst uns doch mal das...
Wenn wir grad schon bei schönen Programmiersprachen sind, Leute.
Lasst uns doch mal das PHP-Video angucken jetzt.
Also, eines der, eines der ekligsten Sachen in C++, finde ich,
ist immer noch diese, diese Chrono Date Time API, die sie da haben.
So, caste Millisekunden in Sekunden und sowas.
Dann lasst uns doch mal schauen, was an PHP so geil ist.
PHP doesn't suck anymore.
Ich glaube ihm sogar, dass die Sprache an sich gar nicht mehr suckt,
aber mir hat das Ökosystem überhaupt nicht zugesagt, das letzte Mal.
Ich kann mich nur noch dunkel dran erinnern, was mich...
Also, wir haben Laravel probiert, letztens in nem Stream.
Ist schon ne Weile her.
Und ich wollte irgendein zusätzliches Package installieren.
Ich glaube, um ein Bild zu rotaten oder sowas.
Irgendein Image-Tool für PNGs.
Und...
Das war super weird, das zu registrieren, dass das überhaupt benutzt wird.
Ja, gucken wir mal.
Also, was erzählt der uns?
Zehn Minuten, das kriegen wir.
Kotlin Ökosystem vs. PHP.
Ja, den Maven-Kram fand ich auch abartig, letztens.
Ich verstehe...
Ganz ehrlich, ich verstehe gar nicht, wie kann das einfach 2023 immer noch
Wobei, also...
IntelliJ hat das schon ganz gut gemacht.
Also, wenn man es einmal hinzugefügt hat, war das auch nicht so viel schlechter als Nougat.
Aus irgendeinem Grund.
Cradle konnten wir nicht verwenden, weil das meine Java-Version nicht unterstützt hat.
Irgendwas war da.
Sonst, ich wollte das verwenden, das ging aber nicht.
Als wir letztens ein bisschen Kotlin-Zeug gebastelt haben.
Und das war schon Painstamp.
Aber ich verstehe es im Jahr 2023 gar nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Wie das sein kann?
Wenn man sich Sprachen anguckt, wie Rust zum Beispiel.
Jetzt können wir wirklich mal Rust positiv erwähnen.
Auch wenn ich Rust ganz gerne mal flame, aber in dem Punkt ist Rust wirklich gut.
Rust hat ein eingebautes Package-Manager-Tool.
Was gescheit funktioniert.
Hat eine halbwegs übersichtliche Config für die Projekte.
Und hat das halt alles built-in.
Hat ein Testing-Tool standardmäßig dabei.
Und das funktioniert einfach.
Ruby hat das seit Anfang an schon.
Ruby gibt es seit 2003 oder seit 20 Jahren.
Hat Ruby einen ordentlichen Package-Manager.
Damals noch richtig was Neues.
Und in C++ hantieren die Leute mit Header-Files.
Und in Java hantieren sie mit irgendwelchen manuellen Bild-Dingern, Skripts.
Es geht immer noch schlimmer.
Header-Files und CMake zusammen.
Aber wie kann es sein, dass Godown die Welt hinzugefügt wird.
In den C++-Standard.
Aber keiner auf die Idee kommt, wie wäre es mal mit einem offiziellen sinnvollen Package-Manager.
Da sind bestimmt schon Leute auf die Idee gekommen.
Aber dann wurde das bestimmt wieder total zerdiskutiert von den C++-Gremiumsleuten.
Composer war das bei PAP.
Nee, bei Laravel war das Artisan oder sowas.
Es ist alles so halb-offizielles Zeug.
Das war von Microsoft vielleicht in dem Ökosystem recht verbreitet.
Warum gibt es keinen offiziellen Package-Manager?
Da versteht man nicht.
So, dann lasst uns nochmal anschauen.
Ich meine, seriously, Header-Files in 2023.
So, mal gucken, warum PAP geil ist.
Bei all den Videos, die ich mache, bekomme ich den gleichen Kommentar.
Rust ist die Zukunft.
Die Rust-Task-Force ist auch schon bei ihm am Start unter den Videos.
PHP, haha, was für ein Witz.
PHP ist langsam, sehr langsam.
Tatsächlich ist es viermal langsamer als .NET.
Da wäre ich mir gar nicht mal so sicher.
.NET ist schon halbwegs geschwind.
Ordentlich programmiert.
Aber ich glaube, bei normalen Standardsachen,
wenn man jetzt mal weg von optimierten Multithreading und C-Interop-Sachen geht,
ich glaube, so langsam ist PAP gar nicht.
Wenn man sich Benchmarks anguckt,
ist PAP noch eine ganze Ecke vor Python und Ruby und sowas.
Also so schlecht ist PAP für die Performance gar nicht.
Okay.
Ist das ein Screenscreen hinter ihm?
Nee, das ist einfach Licht, was ihn von hinten anschreit,
was ein bisschen so einen Outline gibt.
Also, das Beste an Obama fand ich sein Echsenmensch-Bodyguard.
Falls jemand das Revealed-Video kennt dazu.
Toss? Ist das Toss?
Video ist leise?
Das ist volle Pulle?
Ich glaube, das Video ist einfach leise aufgenommen von ihm.
Ja.
Ja, dann?
Hat PAP Types?
Letztes Mal, wo ich mit PAP ein bisschen was gemacht habe,
das war zu Zeiten, wo ich Battlefield 4 Server hatte.
Ich glaube, damals war das noch alles dynamisch.
Aber letztens in Laravel, da hatten wir schon Types, glaube ich.
Bin mir da gar nicht so sicher, ehrlich gesagt.
Das ist tatsächlich cool.
Das ist ein Feature,
das hätte ich, First Class Support, sowas in der Richtung,
hätte ich gerne in C Sharp auch.
Es gibt sowas ähnliches mittlerweile.
Also Interfaces gibt es ja in C Sharp schon ewig.
Aber Interfaces konnten halt lange Zeit keine Logik mitbringen.
Mittlerweile können Interfaces Logik mitbringen.
Also du kannst sowas in C Sharp mittlerweile auch machen
mit Interfaces und Default Implementation.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das so gut funktioniert wie in dem Fall mit PAP.
Ich finde es eine coole Idee.
Es ist halt nicht 3000 objektorientierte Vererbungssachen,
sondern mehr so Add-In mäßig.
Rust kann das ja auch.
Go glaube ich auch.
So schlimm finde ich das jetzt nicht.
Okay, ja.
Das ist natürlich viel besser.
Das sieht halt aus wie in einer normalen,
von Menschen benutzbaren,
von Menschen benutzbare Programmiersprache.
Ecke, Geklammern, Array.
Ich frage mich, ob sie es in PAP backwards compatibility mäßig
noch drin haben, dass du Array schreiben kannst.
Weiß das jemand von euch?
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass sie bei PAP auch die ein oder anderen Sachen
als Making Changes mäßig rausgeschmissen haben über die Jahre.
Was, was C++ sich ja komplett drückt davor das zu machen.
Och ja.
Das finde ich gut.
Nice.
Und ganz ehrlich, eigentlich auch eine ganz brauchbare Syntax.
Kann man sich gut merken.
Das ganze Dollargedöns in PAP finde ich halt ein bisschen affig.
Aber das war schon immer so,
das ist wahrscheinlich was, was man auch so grundlegendes nicht so easy ändern kann.
Da hast du ja Doppeldeutigkeiten dann in der Syntax drin.
Auch gut, auch gut.
Auch gut.
Nicht schlecht, auch gut.
Leute, ich habe fast den Eindruck,
dass es noch Sprachen, Gremium und Standardmacher gibt,
die wissen, wie man das macht.
Okay, der Fairness halber würde ich sagen,
die meisten wissen eigentlich, wie man das macht.
Plus C++ weiß das nicht.
Wie schafft man es, eine Sprache die letzten Jahre über immer mehr zu verkacken
und unlogischer, inkonsistenter zu machen?
Und dann guckt man zu anderen Sprachen rüber, wie PHP in dem Fall sogar,
und da sieht man, guck da, es funktioniert.
Man muss sich nur die C++ Lambda Syntax angucken.
Eckige Klammern und dann noch eine Sache mit Reference Capturen
und Capturen und Auto Capturen und Klammern dahinter,
Klammern nicht dahinter
Alter, wer sich das ausgedacht hat.
Habt ihr mal Async Await gesehen in C++?
Das ist so dermaßen beschissen, das will keiner benutzen.
Auch nicht schlecht.
Und ich finde, eine Sache, ich habe keine große Ahnung von PHP,
aber ich finde, sie haben es geschafft,
sinnvolle Syntax für neue Funktionen zu finden,
die PHP-like aussehen.
Also es ist ja immer blöd, wenn man Konzepte von anderen Sprachen klaut,
die dann aber komplett Alien-mäßig aussehen,
in der jeweiligen Sprache.
Aber ich finde, das ist ein sinnvolles Feature
und das sieht auch irgendwie nach PHP aus.
Ja, und das Punkt für Punkt ist tatsächlich ein bisschen Kack-Java-Skript.
Wobei das in C Sharp mittlerweile auch funktioniert.
So ähnlich, so ähnlich.
Ja, du kannst, wenn du Pattern Matching machst in C Sharp,
kannst du mittlerweile auch sowas wie Punkt, Punkt, Rest vom Array
und sowas verwenden. Das geht mittlerweile.
Ob Pearl auch die ganzen Features mittlerweile hat?
Moment, das ging früher in PHP nicht.
Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, so wenige benutzen PHP gar nicht.
Klar, PHP ist bei weitem nicht mal das,
wenn du mal 15 bis 20 Jahre zurückguckst,
wo eigentlich alles an Web-Anwendungen in PHP war.
Da waren die Zeiten aber auch anders da.
Da waren die Leute auf irgendwelchen billigen Web-Postern.
Da gab es keinen, ich starte mal kurz einen Container in der Cloud,
ich biete mir mal kurz den Linux-Server in den Domain,
und dann war es einfach so,
ich starte mal kurz einen Container in der Cloud,
ich biete mir mal kurz den Linux-Server in den Domain.
Das hat mit PHP nichts zu tun.
Da gab es billigen Web-Posting, Web-Space mit PHP und MySQL,
und es gab nicht viele Alternativen.
Aber trotzdem, ich glaube, so wenig verbreitet ist PHP gar nicht mal.
Und gut, Dingen brauchen Weile, was Sprachenstandards angeht.
Ich kann verstehen, dass sie das nicht vor 10 Jahren alles hinbekommen haben.
Es kann natürlich auch sein, dass sie es vor 10 Jahren auch nicht wollten.
Dann könnte man zu Recht sagen, hätten sie es mal hingekriegt.
Aber, ich meine, ein Negativbeispiel ist C++.
Die haben ganz viel Zeug die letzten 10 Jahre neu hinzugefügt in den Standard,
aber fast nichts davon ist sinnvoll implementiert über die Compiler hinweg.
Also, in der Gänze implementiert.
Also, es ist sehr viel halbherzig implementiert.
Dazu kommt, dass der Standard selbst total uneinheitlich ist.
Mal werden Sachen so benutzt, mal werden Sachen so benutzt.
Da gibt es irgendwelche Typen im Standard, die in 1% der Fällen benutzbar sind.
Also, C++ ist das beste Beispiel dafür,
wie man eine eh schon hässliche Sprache noch weiter verunstalten kann,
mit eigentlich sinnvollen Features, aber nicht gut durchdacht.
Warum hat C++ denn ganz viele Compiler?
Ich würde sagen, es ist wahrscheinlich historisch entstanden,
weil es gibt ja keine wirklich offizielle C++ Implementierung.
Das Offiziellste, was es gibt, ist wahrscheinlich mittlerweile,
GCC ist es nicht, ist wahrscheinlich Clang, wie das die C++ Leute aussprechen.
Also, das LLVM, nee, wie heißt das Ding?
LVM heißt das, gell?
Das ist wahrscheinlich noch das Offiziellste, was es gibt.
Es gibt keinen offiziellen C++ Compiler.
Und dementsprechend ist das alles so,
ja, Microsoft hat dann wieder ihren eigenen Krempel gemacht.
Ich meine, C++ unterstützt halt dadurch enorm viele Plattformen.
Das ist schon ein Vorteil.
Es gibt für jede, hast du nicht gesehen, dahergelaufene Architektur C++,
Compiler, ja, für ESP32, den programmierst du hauptsächlich in C und C++.
Also, es krankt aber, denke ich, schon ein bisschen daran,
auch dass es keine offizielle Implementierung gibt.
Eine offizielle Implementierung hätte den riesen Vorteil,
dass es weniger undefined Behavior gibt.
Da wird nämlich einfach schlicht und ergreifend defined,
wie das Behavior sein soll.
Das Behavior ist, so wie sich die Referenzimplementierung verhält.
Ganz einfach.
Selbst wenn es nicht direkt im Standard in allen Fällen erfasst ist,
so wie sich die offizielle Referenzimplementierung verhält,
ist halt dann, so muss es halt sein.
Und C++ strotzt ja vor undefined Behavior.
Also, das ist wirklich ein gutes Beispiel dafür,
wie man eine eh schon eklige Sprache mit eigentlich sinnvollen Features
noch verwirrender und ekliger machen kann,
wenn man sich nicht richtig durchdenkt C++ die letzten zehn Jahre.
Ja, und das wundert mich, dass C++, äh, sorry, nicht C++,
dass PHP so lange keine, wie nennt man das, wie heißt denn das eigentlich?
Das ist ja, das ist im Prinzip eine Schleife, die unterbrochen wird.
Wie heißt denn das korrekt?
Wie man das nennt?
Alter, auf Deutsch.
Ah, warum ist die fucking Seite auf Deutsch?
Enumeraten.
Generator, ja, das trifft's wahrscheinlich ganz gut.
Genau, ja, Generator, Generator.
Ja, ich glaub, das Generator Function, ja.
Ich will mir nicht sehen, was der offizielle Name dafür ist.
Also, sprich, dass wenn du das hier aufrufst, bekommst du immer eins raus.
Beim nächsten Aufruf noch eins, dann noch eins, dann noch eins,
ohne dass es hängt.
Das ist halt eigentlich ganz cool.
Verwendet man recht selten, aber wenn man's braucht,
ist nice, dass es das gibt.
Ah, ist das die PHP-Version von Extension Methods?
Das ist so ein bisschen wie Extension Methods,
nur vielleicht ein bisschen ekligere Syntax.
So, das mit diesem File bei PHP finde ich auch immer eklig.
Ja, das haben sie sich wahrscheinlich von C++ abgeguckt.
Aber warum nicht einfach einen Punkt?
So ein Punkt ist einfach deutlich nicer als so ein File.
Und mich würde nicht wundern,
wenn ein Punkt nicht sogar in einer ordentlichen IDE
translated wird zu einem File.
Ja, in C++ gibt's einen Punkt.
Gut, in C-Style-Sprachen macht's ja auch einen Sinn,
warum's ein Punkt ist, beziehungsweise ein File.
File ist Pointer dereferenzieren und dann auf den Inhalt zugreifen.
Und Punkt ist quasi direkt auf eine Stackvariable Inhalt zugreifen,
ohne dereferenzieren.
In C++, im C-Kontext, wo man Pointer und Nicht-Pointer und so hat,
da macht es Sinn.
In C-Sharp gibt es das ja prinzipiell auch.
Alle Objects sind Referenzen
und alle primitiven Sachen sind Values,
wobei das halt die Sprache,
beziehungsweise die Runtime für dich unter der Haube handelt.
Und da brauchst du auch nur noch einen Punkt.
Wo du es in C-Sharp auch brauchst,
ist wenn du Unsave-Code verwendest.
Dann brauchst du auch diesen File.
Ja, wobei ich mir bei Go immer nie ganz sicher bin,
ob ich's richtig mache mit den Pointern.
In C++ auch nicht.
Also das ist sowas wie Extension Methods.
Das finde ich eigentlich eine gute Sache,
dass PHP das hat.
Also, was bin ich hier überhaupt sehend?
Was bin ich hier überhaupt sehend?
Moment, hä?
Nee, Moment.
Hä? Was bin ich hier überhaupt sehend?
Das sind keine Extension Methods, das sind...
Was ist das?
Okay, das ist eine Klasse,
die keinen Namen hat in dem Sinn.
Aber...
Also da verstehe ich den Sinn davon ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Warum kann man nicht oben einfach drüberschreiben
Okay, doch, ich verstehe es.
Das macht...
Okay, das macht Sinn,
wenn viele Libraries und Standardsachen
eben Interfaces erwarten
und du oftmals nur eine Funktion da drin brauchst
und das nur an einer Stelle benutzt.
Da macht's vielleicht der Bequemlichkeit halber
nicht so viel Sinn als eine extra Klasse.
Aber das ist so ein Ding, wo ich mir denke,
okay, das hättest du vielleicht auch nicht gebraucht.
Aber dazu muss man wahrscheinlich ein bisschen in PHP drin sein,
dass man das besser einordnen kann, wie sinnvoll.
Ich finde es erstmal nicht so schlimm,
einfach eine Klasse anzulegen dafür,
meinst so viel...
Du hast ja hier schon mehr oder weniger alles.
Würdest du einfach noch zwei Klammern drumherum machen
und dem Ding einen Namen geben,
dann wär's fertig und wird auch nicht so viel größer.
Aber, ja, okay.
Ich hab erst gedacht, das ist sowas wie Extension Methods,
ist es aber nicht.
...implementation,
but you don't want to make a full class for it.
This is a big one.
I need you to pay very, very close attention.
We now have...
...trailing commas in function calls,
so look very closely at email.
Look at the very end of the word email
and watch what's about to happen.
No!
No! God, please, no!
Das ist ein bescheuertes Feature.
Das soll gefälligst ein Syntaxfehler sein,
wenn du da hinten ein Komma hast.
Was ist der Sinn von einem Komma
in einem Funktionsaufruf,
wenn kein weiterer Parameter kommt?
Das ist doch komplett bescheuert.
Warum ist das erlaubt?
Hat irgendeiner einen Plan,
was der Sinn in PHP davon ist?
Das ist ein Funktionsaufruf
von Compact.
So, erster Parameter,
zweiter Parameter,
dritter Parameter gibt's nicht.
Das soll einen Syntaxfehler geben.
Wo ist der Sinn davon?
Ich versteh's nicht.
Das ist eher was,
was ich nicht haben wollte.
Es ist ja kein Jason hier oder sowas.
Amazing!
We now have trailing commas
in method calls, PHP rules.
Versteh ich nicht so im Sinn.
This one's for all my JavaScript friends.
I know you love your arrow functions.
Well, look out, friends.
Moment, irgendwie ist es gerade
trailing commas in method calls,
PHP rules.
This one's for all my JavaScript friends.
I know you love your arrow functions.
Der Typ ist lauter geworden auf einmal.
Well, look out, friends.
We've got arrow functions, too.
Our...
Da gucke mal an.
Es gibt ja noch tatsächlich Sprachdesigner,
die es schaffen,
wenn es jetzt vielleicht nicht superhübsch ist
mit FN, Dollar, User und sowas.
Wenn nicht superhübsch,
es gibt ja Sprachdesigner,
die es benutzbar zu gestalten.
Ich meine, habt ihr mal eine Lambda-Syntax
in C++ gesehen?
Okay, das ist jetzt ein bisschen unfair.
Das ist ja nur die Beschreibung davon.
Aber hey,
allein schon die Überschrift, man.
C++ ist echt so eine Sprache
für alle, die auf unleserliche Sonderzeichen
und so stehen.
Fuck!
Guckt euch das mal an!
Das sieht aus,
als hat einer früher noch,
bevor es Emojis gab,
versucht, irgendeinen U-Boot zu designen
oder sowas.
Guckt euch das an!
Alter, ist das abartiger Kack!
Was?
In PHP können die Dinger nur One-Liner sein.
Ja, das ist doof.
Da hätte ich jetzt gedacht,
du könntest...
Hat das einen Grund, warum das...
Ja, weil sie unfähig sind.
Weil die einfach als Sprachdesigner
und nicht nur als Syntax und Language...
Auch die Standard-Library ist Kacke.
Ja, die sind einfach unfähig
oder werden sich nicht einig.
Das ist natürlich blöd,
dass es in PHP nur One-Line geht.
Ich glaube, in Python geht es auch nur One-Line.
Aber dort macht das auch kaum einer.
Auch eine Sache, die mich ein bisschen...
Wir haben ja letztens ein bisschen
so ein Addon programmiert in Python
für meine...
Wir haben ja diesen Wecker
für meine Leiste hier oben,
den man resetten kann und einstellen kann.
Das haben wir in Python programmiert.
Und das ist nicht lang,
das sind 150 Zeilen oder so,
das ist nicht so viel.
Und das hat mich auch immer irritiert,
dass es keine gescheiten
Multiline Lambda-Functions gibt in Python.
Das ist alles so One-Liner-Zeug.
Aber das ist irgendwie auch verpönt
bei den Python-Fans.
Ich weiß auch nicht so genau, warum.
Rust ist auf jeden Fall
schwierig zu lesen an vielen Stellen.
Da gebe ich dir recht.
Deswegen bin ich auch kein so großer Rust-Fan,
ehrlich gesagt.
Rust hat sicherlich unbestreitbar
in manchen Einsatzszenarien seinen Vorteil.
Rust hat, finde ich,
eigentlich nur
bei einer Kategorie Software
wirklich einen riesen Vorteil.
Und zwar, wenn du was haben willst,
was kompromisslos Performance hat
und gleichzeitig
unsafe ist,
also das keine Managed-Sprache ist,
kein Garbage-Kollektor und nichts,
was aber trotz der Unsafeness
trotzdem so safe wie möglich ist.
Also zum Beispiel,
wenn man eine CSS-Engine
für einen Browser programmiert,
dann ist Rust sicherlich eine tolle Sache.
Du willst, dass das so sicher wie möglich ist,
du möchtest so wenig wie möglich
irgendwelche Overflows,
Dangling-Pointer,
Sachen dereferenzieren, einfangen,
in einer security-kritischen Anwendung
wie beispielsweise in einem CSS-Parser
für einen Browser.
Das ist sinnvoll.
Und du willst gleichzeitig,
also das muss so safe wie möglich,
obwohl es unsafe ist, sein
und gleichzeitig möglichst schnell.
Dann ist Rust gut.
Für alles andere, muss ich ehrlich sagen,
dadurch erkauft man sich das mit Rust auch,
zumindest mit einer meiner Meinung nach
deutlich erhöhten Entwicklerzeit
im Vergleich zu anderen Sprachen.
Ich weiß, die Rust-Taskforce und Rewrite
alles in Rust, die sieht das anders.
Die sagen hier, ich habe die komplette
Desktop-Anwendung mit UI.
Weißt du, es gibt Rust-Fanboys,
die sagen, ich habe OBS in drei Tagen programmiert
in Rust, Rewrite, Blazingly Fast,
jetzt alles viel besser und sowas.
Glaube ich ihm aber nicht,
wenn das so ist.
Also, das müsste man mal ausprobieren.
Aber, ich behaupte mal,
dass die allermeisten Entwickler
in Rust deutlich langsamer sind,
was zu entwickeln,
als in einer anderen Sprache,
die sich halt dafür auch eignen würde.
Das Rust, finde ich,
ist eigentlich nur genau in diesem
einem Punkt wirklich gut.
Und dafür ist es wahrscheinlich
auch die beste Sprache, die es gibt.
Aber für alles andere, finde ich,
ist Rust gar nicht so sehr geeignet.
Rust ist mega kryptisch.
Rust besteht aus so viel.
Die haben gefühlt die komplette Tastatur,
also das komplette ASCII-Charset,
für Sonderzeichen in Rust verbraucht.
Fünf Insights vom Google-Rust-Journey.
Okay, wenn Google dazu was sagt.
Sag ich schon mal her.
Was sagt denn Google dazu?
Rust.
Rust takes more than six months
to learn to debunk.
Ich glaube schon,
dass man relativ schnell,
ich glaube, das hat auch so keiner gesagt,
ich glaube schon, dass man relativ schnell
auch in Rust was auf die Reihe kriegt.
Aber wenn man das komplett intus hat,
das dauert sicherlich länger
als bei anderen Sprachen.
Und ich finde auch,
dass selbst gut programmiertes Rust,
das sieht man oftmals an Beispielen
von Rust-Projekten,
trotzdem nicht so schön lesbar ist.
Gerade weil das so viele Sonderzeichen hat.
Also Rust ist schon nicht so ohne,
was es angeht.
Ja gut, was der Rust-Compiler macht,
ich jetzt nicht.
Ach hier, Unsave.
Ich glaube Unsave und Interop
sollte ganz gut gehen in Rust.
Rust has amazing compiler error messages.
Das stimmt.
Das ist mir auch in Rust aufgefallen.
Also wenn man das mal
mit dem C++-Compiler vergleicht,
Rust zeigt dir relativ genau,
wie es funktioniert.
Ja, das ist wirklich gut.
So, gucken wir mal PHP weiter.
Doch hat Rust.
Rust ist deutlich funktionaler
als objektorientiert.
Kann man mit Rust moderne UIs erstellen?
Ja, es gibt die ein oder anderen
UI-Frameworks.
Wie full-featured die sind,
weiß ich nicht.
Habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Ah, das ist nice.
Also wenn das so funktioniert
wie in anderen Sprachen,
dann wird hier vorne geguckt,
ob das null ist
oder eventuell auch false,
wenn es Javascript ist.
Ich glaube in Javascript
könnte es auch false sein.
Bin mir aber nicht sicher.
Vielleicht ist es auch nur
und und und und und und und und und
und und und und und und und und
und und und und und und
Bin mir aber nicht sicher.
Vielleicht ist es auch nur und
und null in Javascript.
Zumindest in C-Sharp ist es so,
das muss null sein.
Wenn das hier null ist,
dann wird das benutzt.
Das benutzt man zum Beispiel
ganz gerne, um Default-Werte zu setzen.
Kurzschreibweise geht übrigens
auch ? gleich.
Ja, ? gleich geht glaube ich
auch in vielen Sprachen.
So we can say the username
is equal to the username
of the unique null-coalescing operator.
But we also have
the null-coalescing assignment.
Ah, sag ich doch.
Leute, man bekommt ja fast
den Eindruck,
dass da an PHP
ein paar Language Designer
gesessen haben,
die was von ihrem Job verstehen.
Which can shorthand
all of that.
Also was C++ Entwickler
anscheinend nicht gewohnt sind.
So, we can say
?
Das ist, das ist auch cool, das ist das mega nice, sowas.
Okay, ja.
erstaunlich nicht mehr benötigt
wenn das nicht genug Grund ist um zu PHP zu wechseln, weiß ich nicht was ich dir sagen soll
okay erinnerst du dich an die Attribute, die ich dir vor fast zwei Sekunden erzählt habe
da gibt es ein Attribut, das ein Argument so sensibel markieren und es von allen Stäbchen redaktieren wird
so dass du nicht zufällig etwas loggierst, was du nicht
auf Sprachniveau sollten, sehr cool, schau dir dieses Wechselstatement an, es ist schrecklich,
es ist riesig, wir hassen es, was wir tun, ist, dass wir einen Statuscode wechseln und dann
in dem Körper jeder Status wir eine Message-Variante einstellen, es muss einen besseren Weg geben,
es gibt einen besseren Weg, wir können jetzt das Match-Statement benutzen und die Message-Variante
zu dem Ergebnis der Match-Statement einstellen und schau, bei 200, 300 können wir mehrere Matches
die gleiche Sache zurückgeben, das ist ein viel kompakterer, viel lesbarerer Weg,
einen Wechselstatement zu schreiben
alles abgeguckt, was in anderen Programmiersprachen so in den letzten 10 Jahren gut funktioniert hat,
aber das ist doch nicht schlimm, das ist doch gut, man muss ja nicht das Rad neu erfinden,
es hat sich bewährt in anderen Sprachen und dematurierend macht es für höchstwahrscheinlich
in PHP auch Sinn, ist das einfach nur ein Switch-Case, nee, ein Switch-Case hättest du keine Variable
am Anfang stehen, sondern du hättest ein Switch-Statement für sich, hier kommt ja quasi
ein Return-Wert raus, der dann da zugewiesen wird. Übrigens, weil wir es gerade von der Rust-Syntax hatten,
Double-Linked List in Java, warum ist das pain? Weil wir es gerade von Rust hatten, ich habe jetzt mal
ein Beispiel gerade hier nebenbei aufgemacht, Tokio ist eines der größten so IO-Frameworks in Rust,
so, das ist kein super ekliges Beispiel, aber es ist gut, es ist hübsches Rust und ich finde schon
an hübschem Rust sieht man, dass es eben nicht ganz so eindeutig ist, guckt euch mal das hier an,
ja, also das kann man alles noch lesen, aber es ist nicht wirklich klar, was da passiert, wenn man
nicht der große Rust-Checker ist. Was passiert hier, Chat? Also ich finde, das ist nicht unbedingt
jetzt gerade so auf den ersten Blick klar, so, das hier verstehe ich noch, Async-Function
createDir, so heißt das Ding, alles gut, so, jetzt Variable, ok, beziehungsweise Parameter,
ok, sRefPath, so, das ist das erste, wo ich mir denke, ok, keine Ahnung, was das macht,
ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, dass hier hinter jetzt der Datentyp kommen muss von dem Parameter,
bedeutet das hier, dass jeder Datentyp erlaubt ist, der dieses Interface implementiert? Wahrscheinlich,
kann man sich dann auch noch zusammen reimen, ja, kommt man mit der Zeit drauf. Dann gibt es
einen Return-Wert von IO-Result, ein generic IO-Result vom Typ, geschweifte Klammer auf,
geschweifte Klammer zu, was auch immer es ist, dann haben wir typische Rust-Magic,
pathAsRefToOwned, das ist, dass der Borrow-Checker nicht meckert beim Kompilieren,
so, dann wird AsyncifyMove oder oder, ich glaube ja, dass dieses oder oder, das ist kein oder an
der Stelle in Rust, das ist ein, also so eine Art Inline-Block, also man könnte hier auch,
ja, keine Ahnung, wie man das nennt in Rust. Und am Ende kommt da noch ein Punkt Await dran,
wo ich sage, was auch immer, wie jetzt, genau. Also das kann man schon lesen, ja, aber ich finde,
man erkennt daran schon, dass Rust, gerade wenn es dann auch ein bisschen mehr wird,
doch schon eine Sprache ist mit viel Komplexität drin, wo auch gerne mal so ein Quellcode-File
komplett voll sein kann, es springt dich gefühlt die ganze Datei mit Sonderzeichen entgegen. Aber
wenn man jetzt hier durchguckt, wird man sicherlich noch ein bisschen, keine Ahnung,
ein bisschen mehr finden. Ja gut, das sind Rust-Imports, die gehen ja noch halbwegs. Da
gibt es diese MagicStruct-Geschichten, zwischendrin hast du vielleicht noch ein
paar Makros oder sowas. Das ist halt wirklich auch schon sehr ordentliches Rust hier. Aber ganz ehrlich,
wenn ich so diesen Text vor mir habe, es ist schon ein bisschen mühselig zu lesen. Und das
ist noch sehr hübsches Rust. Ist schon teilweise ein bisschen mühselig zu lesen. Aber das geht ja
echt noch klar hier. Da hat sich auch einer wirklich Mühe gegeben hier. Ja gut, genug Rust.
Was hältst du von Recruitern auf LinkedIn? Eher Abstand oder kann man das mal machen? Warum nicht?
Wenn die ein gutes Angebot haben, scheiß doch drauf, von wo es kommt. Spricht nix dagegen. Die
werden dir alle möglichen Bullshit erzählen. Du musst halt gucken, ob da was dran ist. Die verdienen
ja auch fett Geld an der Vermittlung. Du musst halt gerade dann, wenn du dort mal vor Ort bist,
die wollen dich ja irgendwo hinvermitteln, auf den Zahn fühlen, ob das auch alles so stimmt. Aber
warum nicht? Wenn da ein gutes Angebot dabei ist, würde ich jetzt kein Problem sehen. Denkst du,
es lohnt sich momentan Informatik zu studieren? Klar, warum nicht? Wenn das das ist, wo du Bock
drauf hast und was dir vorschwebt. Sicher, dass du jetzt davon ausgehen kannst, dass du mit einem
Informatikstudium prinzipiell mehr Geld verdienst, als mit einer Ausbildung, ist im Durchschnitt so.
Für dich individuell muss das allerdings nicht zutreffen. Du kannst mit einer Physiausbildung
genauso gut Fettkohle machen in der IT wie als studierter Informatiker. Ja, das stimmt wohl.
Leider gibt es immer noch kein gescheites Rust für einen ESP32. Es gab so ein paar Versuche,
aber das ist glaube ich nie so, nie irgendwas wirklich gut Benutzbares rausgekommen. Was
hältst du davon, als Freelancer zu arbeiten? Hast du mal überlegt, das selbst zu machen? Ja,
das habe ich überlegt. Aber um mal auf die Sache von vorhin zurückzukommen. Chat,
was meint ihr, warum ich das nicht gemacht habe? Ihr werdet nicht drauf kommen. Korrekt,
weil ich zu faul bin. Da musst du dich um jeden Mist selber kümmern. Mir geht das ja mit Twitch
und YouTube schon auf den Sack. Und da muss ich einmal im Jahr mein Zeug zum Steuerberater
schicken, so nach dem Motto. Und nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, das gebe ich mir nicht. Das mache
ich nicht. Also ich kenne einige, wo sich das wirklich gelohnt hat, geldtechnisch als Freelancer
zu arbeiten. Aber auch viele von denen, gerade die, die ich schon ein bisschen länger kenne,
die sind auch nicht mehr als Freelancer tätig. Kohlemäßig hat es sich gelohnt, aber vieles ging
ihnen wahrscheinlich zu sehr auf den Keks. Also locker die Hälfte von denen, die ich jetzt über
die Jahre kennengelernt habe, arbeiten mittlerweile festangestellt wieder irgendwo. Nunja. So,
PHP, weiter. Ja, Pattern Matching in PHP, coole Sache. Finde ich nice, dass das drin ist. Sollte
eigentlich jede Sprache haben. Schade, dass Javascript das Ganze nicht hat. Man kann das
sicherlich in Javascript in irgendeiner Art und Weise mit Inline-Funktionen oder sowas vielleicht
ähnlich nachbauen. Aber es wäre cool, wenn Javascript sowas auch hätte. C Sharp hat es
mittlerweile und zwar richtig gute Implementierung, wie ich finde. Ich habe eine Weile gebraucht,
mich in C Sharp an die Switch-Syntax zu gewöhnen. Aber ich finde, seit der letzten C Sharp-Version
wurde jetzt auch dieses Array-Selector und sowas dabei. Nee, nee, wie heißt das? Diese Array-Teile,
Selector, Matcher dabei haben. Das ist richtig gut. Äh, ich bin auch nicht gut.
Wait a minute, sollte nicht alles Garbage-Collected werden, was keine Reference mehr hat?
Der einzige Grund, warum ich in C Sharp mal eine Weak-Map verwendet habe. Es gab zwei Sachen und
ich kriege beide nicht mehr so hundertprozentig hin. Das eine, also es waren beides was Garbage-Collector
mäßiges. Das erste war irgendwelches WebRTC-Zeug im Backend, wo ich in der WebRTC-Session
initialisiert habe, die nicht ordentlich Garbage-Collected wurde, weil, ich bin mir nicht
mehr ganz sicher, weil es irgendwie eine Referenz auf sich selbst hat oder irgendwie. Es war wir.
Ich kriege es nicht mehr genau zusammen. Da muss ich eine Weak-Map verwenden. Ah,
ich weiß es wieder. Ich weiß es wieder. Ich weiß es wieder, weil ich sowas gemacht habe. Ich hoffe,
ich kriege das jetzt noch zusammen. Warte mal. Weil ich sowas, nur mal kurz als Beispiel,
weil ich sowas in der Richtung gemacht habe. Ja, ein bisschen Platz hier unten. Okay,
haben wir jetzt nicht, aber ich versuche es euch mal zu zeigen. Ich habe sowas in der Richtung
gemacht. Und zwar habe ich dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, war, keine Ahnung, blubb, gleich,
new. So, keckel. So, das ist meine Klasse. Dann habe ich gesagt, keckel.callback oder was weiß
ich hier, onload oder so oder onconnect oder was auch immer. Und da drinnen habe ich dann,
ups, da drinnen habe ich dann, glaube ich, Moment, ist auch falsch, weiß ich nicht mehr. Darin habe
ich dann, glaube ich, irgendwie auf blubb, keine Ahnung, i oder so zugegriffen. Irgendwie so in der
Richtung muss das gewesen sein. Ich kriege es nicht mehr ganz zusammen. Und da gab es dann
Probleme, dass es nicht Garbage Collected werden konnte in diesem Umstand, weil hier gibt es eine
Referenz auf das und das hat eine Referenz. Also, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es so war. Ja,
es könnte auch irgendein Event gewesen sein. Zumindest hat es da mit dem Garbage Collect
nicht funktioniert. Und da musste ich auch in irgendeiner Art und Weise so eine Weakmap-Referenz
Zeug verwenden, dass es funktioniert. Und das andere, wo ich mal in C-Sharp eine Weakmap-Referenz
verwendet habe, war zum Debuggen vom Garbage Collector selbst, um zu gucken, ob ein Objekt
aufgeräumt wird vom Garbage Collector. Ihr könnt euch vorstellen, es ist gar nicht so
einfach zu checken, ob ein Objekt vom Garbage Collector aufgeräumt wird. Weil, sobald ihr in
das Objekt reinguckt, hat es eine Referenz und wird nicht Garbage Collected. Versteht ihr,
was ich meine? Also, wenn ich jetzt so etwas hier habe, war blubb, ja, war blubb 1. So,
und ich habe jetzt hier im Hintergrund irgendwas, was checken soll, ob das schon
aufgeräumt ist. Task run, Task run. So, ich gucke jetzt hier im Hintergrund immer nach,
ob hier while true await task delay. Also, ich gucke jetzt einmal in der Sekunde nach,
ob blubb schon aufgeräumt wurde. Das ist das Problem. Sobald ich hier auf blubb zugreife,
dann hat es ja eine Referenz und dementsprechend wird es nie Garbage Collected. Ihr versteht das
Problem wahrscheinlich. So, und da musste man auch irgendwie weak reference. Keine Ahnung mehr,
wie das genau ging. Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Ich glaube, das muss man sogar vorher anlegen. Und
dann konnte man mit einer weak reference checken, ob denn das Objekt noch alive ist. Check if gets
Garbage Collected. Das war echt sehr durch die... How to tell if an Object has been Garbage
Collected. Hier, weak reference, genau. Is alive kann man dann checken, korrekt. Genau,
dafür habe ich das mal gebraucht, für diese zwei Sachen. Aber ansonsten eigentlich nie. So,
und deswegen weiß ich auch nicht, wie das PHP wahrscheinlich ähnlich ist. Weak map ist wie
HashMap. Das heißt, das Ganze, was ich euch jetzt erzählt habe, war umsonst, weil es eigentlich um
was ganz anderes geht. Na gut, dann geht es halt um was anderes. Ich muss mal kurz den Kram aufräumen,
sonst wundere ich mich das nächste Mal, warum mein Kram hier nicht mehr funktioniert. Okay,
excellent. Enums in PHP, auch so ein Ding, wo ich mich wundere, warum es das nicht schon
länger gegeben hat. Und warum braucht es da drinnen ein Case? Wahrscheinlich nur,
weil sich irgendein Language Designer gedacht hat, das ist eine coole Sache,
dass da ein Case davor steht. Macht doch, macht doch ernsthaft, macht doch überhaupt keinen Sinn,
dass da ein Case davor steht, oder? Außer, dass man mehr schreiben muss.
Also ich habe mir sagen lassen, dass, weil in TypeScript, in TypeScript gibt es ja Enums,
und ich habe mir sagen lassen, dass selbst in TypeScript, wo es Enums gibt, davon abgeraten
wird, Enums zu verwenden und anstatt dessen plain JavaScript Objekte zu verwenden. Also
vielleicht doch nicht so geil. Gibt es das nicht? Kein Enums in Go? Nee, anscheinend nicht. Was ist
das? In your database, you can do that with a backed enum. That's not all that enums can do.
You can add methods to your enum classes. What? Dann ist es aber doch kein richtiger
Enum mehr, oder? Auf der anderen Seite, so schlecht finde ich das gar nicht mal. So
schlecht finde ich das eigentlich gar nicht. Gerade für sowas, wie zum Beispiel Output
formatieren und sowas. Warum nicht? Ich meine, es gibt jetzt wenig Anwendungsfelder, wo ich mir
denke, ja, das hätte ich jetzt mal gebraucht auf einem Enum. Aber ich könnte mir irgendwelche
Sonderfälle schon vorstellen, wo das sinnvoll ist. Auf der anderen Seite, ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob man das in C Sharp nicht mittels Extension Methods auch erledigen kann. Ich glaube,
das geht. Ich glaube, du kannst in C Sharp Extension Methods auf Enums machen. Macht
man selten, aber ich glaube, das geht. Lass uns das doch gerade mal ausprobieren. Enum,
keck w Enum. Oh, hier, 0. Bester Enum überhaupt. So, und jetzt? Public static class extensions.
Oh, Extension Methods aus dem Kopf, Alter. Wie geht das nochmal hier? Public void,
ja, keine Ahnung hier. Display, nennen wir es doch mal so, wie hier. Display und dann macht
man, glaube ich, this, keck w Enum. Static muss das nicht sein, aber das muss, das muss static
sein. This Enum, eh, ist das verkehrt? Muss doch static sein, Public, ja. So, und jetzt sagen wir,
ja, jetzt haben wir einen Enum Extended, das funktioniert. 0 gleich keck w Enum. Display,
ja klar, geht. Man kann Enums Extenden, aber ehrlich gesagt, mir fällt kein Fall ein,
wo ich das mal gemacht habe bisher. Aber es geht, es geht. Insofern, why not? In PHP gibt es ja
keine Extension Methods. Warum also nicht? Finde ich, finde ich nicht so schlecht.
Oh man, das sind nur Type Hints. Also PHP ist nach wie vor komplett dynamisch. Das heißt,
ich kann da reinstecken, was ich will. Oder gibt es irgendeinen Compiler Flag, so nach dem Motto,
geht nicht. Na gut, wenn das dynamisch ist, weiß gar nicht, ob das alles Compile Time,
Runtime wird, das geht schlecht. Weil zur Compile Time kannst du das ja gar nicht alles,
rausbekommen dann. Oder das ist wenigstens zur Build Time, dann gibt es ja nur Runtime. Ja,
ihr habt recht. Das ist wenigstens irgendwie so zur Build Time, wenn du dann dein Projekt da
generieren lässt, was auch immer, dass es da vielleicht einen Check gibt. Also zur Runtime
wird das gecheckt. Oh, ist doch auch okay. Also,
übrigens, was ich sehr schön finde, dass die eine ordentliche Schreibweise für den Typ haben. Ich
mag, ich mag ja diese Sachen nicht, ja. Also es gibt so einen Trend, so in etwas neueren Sprachen,
da macht man gerne, wo haben wir denn hier eine, da hat man ja hier gerne dann sowas drinnen hier.
Stopping Token ist dann sowas. Der Typ kommt dann dahinter und sowas. Oder in Rust macht man dann
irgendwie, keine Ahnung, let mut i32 blubb gleich 1 und so Dinger muss man da in Rust machen. Nee,
Moment, das ist dann glaube ich doppelt, nee. Oder ist das sogar so in Rust? Ich kann es mir
gar nicht merken. Also ich finde es schön, dass sie es in PHP gemacht haben, so wie ich es
eigentlich auch erwarten würde. Nämlich den Typ davor und ohne Sonderzeichen und gut, es hat auch
keinen Doppelpunkt dazwischen. In Go ist es glaube ich auch so merkwürdig mit Doppelpunkten und sowas
dazwischen. Und auch umgedreht, glaube ich. In Go hast du doch das zuerst, dann Doppelpunkten,
dann Int. Also das finde ich schön, dass die sich, ja, den Return-Type kann man sich jetzt streiten,
ob das dahinter soll oder nach vorne. Ich persönlich mag es, wenn er vorne steht,
bin ich einfach dran gewöhnt. Aber das ist auch okay, solange es nicht so eine hässliche C++
Syntax mit einem Pfeil dahinter ist.
Ja, ist es. Ist es. Aber es verhält sich doch ein bisschen anders, wenn du irgendwie so,
sagen wir mal, klassenweite Variablen anlegen willst, ohne sie gleich zu initialisieren,
kannst du nur var.plop verwenden und das ist initialisieren, also deklarieren und initialisieren
in einem. In dem Fall macht es, glaube ich, das gleiche in Go, aber man braucht trotzdem
manchmal diese Kurzschreibweise hier. Ja, ist eigentlich fast normal, wenn man hauptsächlich
in einer Sprache unterwegs ist. Ich finde es auch immer ein bisschen merkwürdig,
wenn ich zwischen C Sharp Backend und JavaScript Frontend wechseln muss und ich mich dann auch
manchmal vertippe, wenn man, wenn man, wenn man immer switcht und gleichermaßen dort was macht
drin und dort, dann geht das. Aber wenn man, sagen wir mal, 95 Prozent Backends, Frontend
Sachen gerade macht und dann mal ein bisschen was hinzufügen will, dann verschreibst du dich
auch öfters mal. Wo sind wir stehen geblieben hier?
Das ist cool. Das ist mega. Das würde ich mir in C Sharp auch wünschen. Und das bin
ich nicht der Einzige. Das wünschen sich gefühlt 55, die gesamte Weltbevölkerung,
aber Microsoft hat keinen Bock drauf. Das wäre mega nice. Ja, wenn das gehen würde.
Ja, kannst du auch Object nehmen für alles. Da musst du halt innen drinnen wieder casten.
Doch, doch, das ist in der Diskussion, aber irgendwie kommt Microsoft nicht zu Pötte
damit. Das wäre richtig cool, wenn das geht. Sie haben ja ein bisschen was in die Richtung
gemacht. Vor zwei ist die Sharp Version mit ihren I Number Interfaces und sowas. Aber
das löst das Problem nicht wirklich. Das ist blöd. Das ist so das letzte Feature für
C Sharp, was ich mir eine Weile wünsche, was einfach nicht kommt. Das wäre cool,
wenn Microsoft sich da mal zusammenreißt und sowas auf die Reihe kriegt. Es gibt ja
schon Libraries, die das in C Sharp machen. Zum Beispiel das hier. Da kann man schreiben
Return Type ist one of User Invalid Name or Name Taken. Das ist schon ganz cool, aber
es wäre halt deutlich nicer, wenn das in der Sprache selbst mit abgebildet wäre und
sei es nur, dass es so einen Typ in der Standard Library gibt. Das sollte eigentlich nicht
so kompliziert sein. Und Microsoft hat sich die letzten Jahre nicht mit Ruhm bekleckert
in C Sharp, da nur sinnvolle Features mit reinzunehmen. Insofern wäre cool, wenn sowas
kommt. Es wäre natürlich noch nicer, wenn das syntaktisch ein bisschen schöner unterstützt
werden würde. Dadurch, dass es eben in die Sprache eingebaut wird. Das ist gar nicht
wieder das aktuelle Proposal aussieht. Gucken wir mal, falls das das aktuelle ist. Proposals.
Vor drei Jahren gibt es das schon. Schreibt es bitte noch. Das ist für den Compiler-Syntax.
Ich verstehe auch nicht mal, was er mir damit sagen will, ehrlich gesagt. Inam Class Shape.
Es kann quasi ein Rectangle oder ein Circle sein. Okay, das ist so als Union-Type quasi.
Es ist ein Shape und im Endeffekt akzeptiert es Rectangles und so. Okay, da findet man
vielleicht noch ein bisschen schönere Syntax für. Also das wäre nice, wenn es sowas gäbe noch. Also
PAP, guck mal, PAP hat das schon. Das ist nice. Auch Shake. Ja. Ja.
Das ist Interface, oder? So nach dem Motto, ich will, dass nur noch was reingesteckt werden kann,
was die, das Interface und das Interface. Ja, okay.
Oder Trades, besser gesagt. Ja, hat Trade Foo und Trade Bar, könnte man so sagen in PAP.
Okay, jetzt wird es wirklich wild langsam. Jetzt wird es langsam abgedreht.
Disjunctive Normal Form Type. Alles klar, Leute, ihr wisst, wenn ihr demnächst glänzen wollt mit
eurem Progress-Kenntnissen. Ich habe schon wieder vergessen. Disjunctive Normal Form Type.
Disjunctive Normal Form Type.
Okay, das soll mit einem der nächsten C-Sharp-Versionen
auch kommen. Aber ich bin da kein allzu großer Fan von. Ich finde, ich finde das hier gar nicht
mal so übel, zumal es die Idee für dich macht. Und es gab noch ein paar andere Dinger, die ich
etwas doof fand, wie sie das in C-Sharp implementieren wollten. Nämlich nicht auf Constructor. Genau,
jetzt weiß ich es wieder. Ne, so fände ich es durchaus auch in Ordnung, wenn sie es in C-Sharp
gemacht hätten. Aber in C-Sharp kommt das auf den Class, auf Class-Ebene hier oben soll das
hinkommen. Und dann hast du das Problem, dass Records, Structs und Classes mit solchen Constructoren
alle gleich aussehen und sich ein bisschen unterschiedlich verhalten. Und das sollte
nicht sein. Ja, das habe ich in .NET beziehungsweise in
C-Sharp auch nicht verstanden. Warum sie dort .NET eingeführt haben und warum man nicht auch
einfach sagen konnte, irgendwie SetReadOnly oder sowas. Also warum die da wieder ein eigenes Keyword
für gebraucht haben. Also ehrlich, ich würde sagen PHP ist vollkommen okay. Von der Geschwindigkeit
her für das meiste.
Das Argument zählt nicht. Das Argument zählt nicht. Es ist egal, ob du 50.000 User oder keine
Ahnung, tausend User hast, wenn das dazu führt, dass der einzelne User einfach schneller seine
Seite sieht. Also sprich, ja, ich kann 50.000 Requests die Sekunde ab, weil jeder einzelne
Request eben so performant ist, dass ich 50.000 Sekunde schaffe. Wenn es nur tausend Leute
benutzen, sind die Requests für die tausend Leute trotzdem schneller durch. Also insofern
finde ich das nicht zu vernachlässigen. Allerdings glaube ich, dass es in dem Fall trotzdem kein
wirklich großer Negativpunkt für PHP ist, weil es wahrscheinlich in dem Bereich ist,
dass es nicht ausschlaggebend ist. Also keine Ahnung, hast du deine Response jetzt in 5
Millisekunden oder in 4, so nach dem Motto. Ob du es in 150 oder in 50 hast, das ist schon
wieder ein anderer Punkt. Alles über 150 ist eh indiskutabel. Und die Latenz über die Leitung
kommt ja noch dabei. Wenn dein Server schon 150 Millisekunden braucht, die Response zu generieren,
und du hast noch 150 Millisekunden Ping, da dauert es 300 Millisekunden bis ein Teil von
der Seite. Das dauert das Seitenladen ewig, da schlägst die Leute schon wieder runter und du
verkaufst nichts. Das stimmt ja gar nicht, die Anfrage muss ja auch erstmal hin. Das sind dann
sogar 450 Millisekunden. Das ist zu lang. Ja, glaube ich eben. Warum kriege ich eigentlich
irgendwelches Commodore-Zeug empfohlen? Ja, ich fand es ein gutes Video. Also ich glaube ihm sofort,
dass er PHP mag und dass PHP nicht mehr Kacke ist. Ich habe letztens PHP ausprobiert und das,
was ich gesehen habe, davon fand ich jetzt nicht so geil. Aber das war eher aus Sachen drumherum.
Go 1.21 Features. Das sagt mir nichts. Wobei, das ist keine Anwendung. Das sind irgendwelche
Struktogramme oder sowas. Keine Ahnung, ob das bei uns benutzt wird. Ich meine, ich bin kein
hauptberuflicher Entwickler. Also ich mache sowas schon mal gar nicht und ich habe es auch noch von
keinem Architekt oder so bisher bei uns gesehen. Zumindest nicht wissentlich, dass das BPMN ist.
Wie sieht denn das aus? BP und dann was? MN. Oh, 2.0. Da gibt es Weiterentwicklung von Web 5.0.
Doch, das kann durchaus sein, dass ich sowas in der Richtung schon mal gesehen habe. Doch,
doch, das kommt mir bekannt vor. Aber ich habe schon so viele dieser Diagrammtypen gesehen.
Keine Ahnung, ob es jetzt explizit ein BP Dingsbums gewesen ist. Sie sehen es sich ja alle
ähnlich. Wechseln Sie meine Rolle vom Software-Engineer zum DevOps-Engineer innerhalb der
Firma, wo ich aktuell arbeite. Hast du irgendwelche Tipps? Ja, beschäftige dich mit
Linux. Also je nachdem, was ihr macht. Aber Linux-Know-How finde ich wichtig, gerade in dem
Job. Natürlich auch ein bisschen hängt es davon ab, was du machen sollst später. Mein DevOps ist
ja so ein Ding, was überall drauf gekleistert wird, gelabelt wird mittlerweile. Ein bisschen
drauf an, was du machen sollst. Aber beschäftige dich mit Linux. Es sei denn, ihr seid eine
Microsoft-Windows-Only-Bude, aber da hätte ich eh keinen Bock. Aber beschäftige dich mit Linux.
Und auch mit dem, was da noch so dazugehört mit der Zeit. Gerade im DevOps-Bereich misse ich
wahrscheinlich dann mit irgendwelchen Automatisierungssachen für Builds oder für
Deployment oder für Cloud-Infrastruktur, was auch immer noch beschäftigen müssen. Also
du brauchst solides Linux-Know-How. Wenn es um Infrastruktur geht, sowas wie Terraform.
Wenn es so wirklich klassische VMs sind, dann auch vielleicht sowas wie Ansible. Ja,
eines der gängigen Continuous-Integration-Dinger kann auch meinetwegen Jenkins sein. Ich verstehe
nicht, warum Jenkins so viel Hate immer abbekommt. Ich mag Jenkins, wenn ich auch keine Jenkins-
Installation mehr selbst betreiben möchte. Also du hast jetzt im Chat gelesen, ja, anscheinend
machen das einige. Also ich nicht. Wenn mir einer mit Diagrammenmalen ankommt,
dann suche ich immer das Weite. Ist ja auch meistens. Das sollen irgendwelche
Highly-Paid-Consultants machen und mich damit in Ruhe lassen. Ich will keine Diagramme malen.
Leute, ich hab Hunger. 22.30 Uhr. Ich esse jetzt aber nix mehr. Früher hätte ich mir jetzt noch
eine Backofen-Pizza reingeschmissen und hätte die gefressen. Ach, ich hab euch ja das neueste
Zeug gar nicht erzählt. Ich hab ja auf Twitter gepostet, dass ich... Moment, ich such's mal raus.
Max FPS. Man kann ja so nicht mehr auf Twitter, weil es sonst rumbuckt. Twitter immer mehr suckt.
Ja, ich hab euch doch mal gezeigt, dass ich angefangen hab wieder ein bisschen zu rennen.
Und das war, das war die... Das ist schlecht. Das war mein zweiter, mein zweiter Tag, wo ich gerannt bin,
ja. Und ich hab jetzt seitdem jeden... Also was heißt seitdem? Also 14.30 Uhr. Ich hab jetzt die
Woche durch jeden zweiten Tag meine Runde gedreht. Und die letzte Runde war 6,07 Kilometer. Das ist
die, die ich jetzt in Zukunft noch weiter laufen werde. Und jetzt hat sich das eingependelt. Also
ich hab jetzt Durchschnitt, Durchschnitt 8,823 für, also für den Kilometer im Durchschnitt. Ich kann euch,
wenn ihr es genauer wisst, weil ich kann euch das mal vorlesen. Wo ist denn Garmin-App? Und was machst
du nach der Aufwärmrunde? Ich lauf meine eineinhalb, zwei Stunden auch sonst noch, die ich vorher auch
schon immer gelaufen bin. Also ich mach jetzt seit Jahren schon, geh ich ein bisschen hier im Umland
wandern, so eineinhalb, zwei Stunden. Jetzt nicht super schnell, aber jetzt auch nicht getrödelt, ja.
Und das mach ich nach wie vor. Ich mach das jetzt, aktuell mach ich das so. Morgens 7 Uhr fang ich
ja ungefähr, oder kurz vor 7 Uhr fang ich ja auf der Arbeit an. Und da ist eh noch keiner da. Dann
geh ich erstmal noch 45 Minuten AFK, nachdem ich was gegessen hab. Und renn mal eine Runde, so 45
Minuten. Und wenn ich wiederkomme, sind dann auch die ersten Leute schon da. So, also ich hatte jetzt
hier, ich guck mal kurz in meinen Kalender. Gestern. Gestern bin ich hier running. Gestern
bin ich gerannt, 6,07 Kilometer. Also das sieht man jetzt nicht hier, aber ich kann's zum Vergleich,
also ich glaub jetzt hat sich ein bisschen eingebildet. 6,07 Kilometer. Durchschnittlich
hab ich gebraucht 8,24 Minuten für den Kilometer. Und ich hab 502 Kalorien verbraucht. Es hat 51
Minuten, ziemlich genau, 51,01, 51 Minuten gedauert. Durchschnittliche Herzrate 154,
also quasi auch so wie hier. Und was mir aufgefallen ist, ich werde in der zweiten
Hälfte schneller. Eigentlich hätt ich gedacht, das ist umgedreht. Du bist am Anfang ein bisschen
schneller, umso mehr angestrengt das ist, umso langsamer wird man. Nein, ich werd in der zweiten
Hälfte schneller. Läufst du immer die gleichen, ich hab zwei Strecken mir jetzt ausgesucht,
ja. Ja, aber die sind ungefähr gleich lang. Also das ist einmal die hier, die ist 5,3 Kilometer,
die andere ist 6,6 Kilometer. Ziemlich genau. So, und hier sieht man's auch, ich bin schneller
geworden ab der Hälfte so. Und am Ende hab ich nochmal Vollgas gegeben. So, und guck hier,
man sieht's auch, ich bin schneller geworden. Zumindest, ich hab, also, erster Kilometer,
ok, erster Kilometer war auch relativ schnell. Erster Kilometer 8 Minuten 17, zweiter Kilometer
9 Minuten 5, dritter 8 Minuten 44, vierter 8 Minuten 25, acht Minuten 15, sieben Minuten 53,
ja und die letzten 70 Meter bin ich halt gerannt, das kann man jetzt nicht zurechnen.
Wie motivierst du dich? Also aktuell motiviert mich einfach das, tja, die Sache an sich. Also
optimale Laufgeschwindigkeit, ich hab mich mit der Theorie da nicht großartig beschäftigt.
Optimale Laufgeschwindigkeit ist für mich aktuell das, wo ich, ja, wo es mich am wenigsten nervt,
dass ich laufe, wie soll ich das, also, wo ich mir gar nicht viel Gedanken drüber mache,
dass ich gerade am Laufen bin, so. Das ist für mich die optimale Geschwindigkeit. Das heißt auch,
morgen früh renne ich eine Runde. Jeden zweiten Tag. Also, ich weiß, das haben auch Leute schon
auf Twitter geschrieben, Max, deine Pulsfrequenz ist viel zu hoch, aber ganz ehrlich, ich komme
mir sonst vor, als würde ich übelst schleichen, wenn ich langsamer laufe. Und wenn ich langsamer
laufe, habe ich jetzt auch nicht so einen krass viel niedrigeren Puls für das Verhältnis,
wo ich langsamer laufe. Und für mich ist es tatsächlich so, in dem Dreh am angenehmsten zu
laufen. Natürlich, hier, zum Schluss, ja, hier, habe ich nochmal voll angefangen, los zu flitzen,
ja. Das ist natürlich nichts, was ich im Durchschnitt da machen kann. Hup, ich kann
euch sagen, alle Chat-Geruhe. Oh, wo ist meine Uhr? Ah, die Uhr ist im, die Uhr ist im Bad. Kann
ich jetzt nicht nachgucken. Ja, Ruhepuls habe ich irgendwie 70 oder sowas, ja. Und Blutdruck ist
eigentlich manchmal sogar schon ein bisschen niedrig. Ich hatte, ich hatte letztens, habe ich,
ich glaube, 100, 110 zu 70 oder sowas. Ich glaube, das ist sogar schon ein bisschen zu niedrig,
der Blutdruck. Aber das ist auch nicht schlimm, dann gibt es wenigstens keinen Herzinfarkt und
keinen Schlaganfall. Ja, denke ich, denke ich auch, dass umso geübter ich werde, umso besser,
umso besser wird es, ja. Also Blutdruck ist, ist eigentlich vielleicht, vielleicht schon ein
bisschen zu wenig. Das liegt aber auch daran, dass, also ich nehme ja seit ein paar Jahren,
weil, also ihr müsst, ihr müsst wissen dazu, Leute, die öfters im Stream sind, die wissen das ja,
ich habe so in der Corona-Zeit, habe ich, also viele Leute haben während Corona zugenommen. Ich
habe ungefähr 18 Kilo abgenommen, aber davor habe ich halt viel weniger mich bewegt. Da bin ich auch
viel seltener meine Strecken wandern gegangen und sowas. Und da hatte ich halt schon ein bisschen
Blutdruckprobleme und seitdem habe ich, ich weiß nicht, wie es genau heißt, nehme ich die Minimaldosis
von so, von, von, von Blutdruck-Medikamenten. Also das ist, das ist quasi eine Viertelpille,
ist quasi nix, so gut wie nix drin, aber man hat es direkt gemerkt, das ist runtergegangen. Ne,
ne, ne, ne, ne. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, es ist, ähm, was gibt es denn da noch? Irgendwie
Satan, sonst was. Das ist das, was ein bisschen die Blutgefäße erweitert und deswegen der Blutdruck
runtergeht. Also wahrscheinlich könnte man auch, wenn, wenn, wenn sie es legalisieren würden,
dass man Cannabis raucht, könnte man wahrscheinlich auch das rauchen, ja. Anstatt, anstatt irgendwelche
Pillen einzuschmeißen. So, zumindest, ich, ich nehme das jetzt schon so eine ganze Weile. Seitdem
ist der Blutdruck auch immer wirklich okay gewesen. Jetzt nicht viel zu niedrig, aber auch nicht so,
sondern okay. Aber seitdem ich 18 Kilo abgenommen habe, mich regelmäßig eineinhalb,
zwei Stunden am Tag bewege, plus jetzt noch angefangen habe, zusätzlich noch meine 45,
50 Minuten alle zwei Tage zu rennen, habe ich halt den Eindruck, ich könnte so langsam,
aber sicher auch mal wieder aufhören, den Scheiß zu nehmen. Weil mein Blutdruck ist,
eigentlich war es schon ein bisschen zu niedrig mittlerweile. Also vielleicht sollte ich mal
wieder zum Doktor gehen und sagen, lass doch mal wieder so einen, so einen Langzeit-Blutdruck-Dings,
aber da habe ich keinen Bock drauf. Das ist so ätzend. Musstet ihr das mal machen? Musstet ihr
mal so einen Langzeit-Blutdruck-Test machen mit irgendwie über 24 Stunden, 48 Stunden Blutdruck?
Das ist mega, mega nervig. Ihr kriegt da so ein Ding, was, was, was alle 15 Minuten oder halbe
Stunde oder so anfängt, sich aufzupumpen und Blutdruck zu messen und dann, wenn du nachts
pennen willst, alter, vergiss es, das ist mega für den Arsch. Du willst pennen und auf einmal fängt
es an. So ätzend, man. Das will ich nicht mehr machen. Das will ich nicht machen. Da muss es
halt so timen, dass es gerade zwischen, dass es, dass die Zeit zwischen den Messzyklen dafür
ausreicht. Ab 22 Uhr misst das, glaube ich, auch nur noch alle halbe Stunde oder so. Muss ich halt
bewusst halt sputen. Das ist, das ist richtig nervig. Das ist, also die Blut, also 24 Stunden,
48 Stunden, manche machen das ja eine Woche oder so. Also, ja, sowas, sowas kenne ich ja auch,
sowas habe ich auch irgendwann mal gemacht, ja. Aber für Blutdruck hast du, kriegst du ein
Blutdruckmessgerät mit neben dich, musst du das stellen. Das ist, das ist richtig eklig. Nervig
halt vor allem. Theoretisch sollte ich das mal wieder machen, da müsste ich ja wahrscheinlich
auch keine Pillen mehr nehmen. Aber ich meine, klar, ganz ehrlich, wer hätte damit auch rechnen
können? Ordentlich abgenommen und mehr bewegen. Wer hätte nur denken können, dass man dadurch
einen besseren Blutdruck kriegt? Ist ja, ist ja nicht so, als hätte man es wissen können oder so.
Aber so ist das halt. Vieles weiß man im Vorfeld schon, aber es ist immer noch ein Schritt von,
ich weiß, dass es so ist und ich weiß, dass es nicht gut ist, zu, ich mache es jetzt auch. Wisst
ihr, wie ich meine? Jeder weiß, dass es schlecht ist, wenn man zu fett ist und sich zu wenig bewegt
und ungesunde Sachen frisst und so. Jeder weiß auch, dass Rauchen ungesund ist, ja. Aber der
Schritt von zu wissen und daraus dann auch was abzuleiten und zu machen, das ist halt der schwerste
oftmals. Als erstes musst du es erstmal erkennen, aber ich glaube, so grundlegende Sachen haben
viele schon erkannt. Aber du musst es dann halt auch machen und das ist echt nicht so ohne.
Immutable Bite, danke für den Sub. Und hätte mir das vor, keine Ahnung, 10 Jahren jemand gesagt,
hätte gesagt, Max, guck mal hier, das ist ungesund und mach doch mal hier, hätte ich gesagt, alter,
verpiss dich, geh mal nicht auf den Sack, ich würde 24-7 Kreiselcrying vorm Rechner machen,
ich will nicht, will nicht raus. Ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich jetzt lieber rausgehe unter Leute
oder so, aber wenn ich nicht täglich meine Runde mache, meine 1,5-2 Stunden, ich sag das absichtlich
so vage, weil das je nach Runde ist. Heute war, ich hab meine Uhr nicht da, also heute war die
Wanderrunde, kann ich euch sagen, war, ich hab da jetzt hier meinen Fitness-Tracker, 1,5 Stunden,
eine Stunde 32,28 war das heute. Das war aber keine Runde, wo ich joggen war, sondern wirklich
nur wandern, Berg, 240 Meter hoch, 240 Meter runter und da hatte ich auch nur einen durchschnittlichen
Puls von 109. Und das mache ich jetzt schon eine Weile, jeden Tag, aber wirklich jeden Tag,
Ausnahme ab und zu mal sonntags nicht, aber ansonsten jeden Tag, jeden Tag 1,5-2 Stunden
wandern gehen hier so im Gelände drumherum und jetzt zusätzlich noch alle zwei Tage eine Runde
rennen, morgen früh ist es wieder soweit. Yep, yep, clock. Nee, das ist runtergegangen. Glaub,
da wird sich nichts mehr tun. Wie gesagt, aktuell motiviert mich einfach nur die Sache an sich. Also
das mit dem Wandern auf jeden Fall ist einzig und allein die Sache an sich, weil mir fehlt jetzt
auch richtig am Tag was, wenn ich keine 1,5 Stunden mal ein bisschen durch den Wald oder
übers Feld oder so gelaufen bin. Aktuell jeden zweiten Tag eine Runde joggen gehen,
das motiviert mich tatsächlich auch noch, noch die Sache an sich. Mir macht das tatsächlich Spaß,
auch wenn es mega anstrengend ist. Vielleicht lässt das nach mit der Zeit. Also eine Sache,
die mich jetzt beispielsweise schon extrem motiviert hat, ist, als ich angefangen habe,
mein erster Test war glaube ich 3,1 Kilometer. So weit bin ich die letzten 15 Jahre dann immer
am Stück gerannt. Und da hatte ich übelst Muskelkater, aber richtig krass Muskelkater
den Tag danach. Ein paar Tage davor bin ich noch ein bisschen kürzer gelaufen, da hatte ich Muskelkater
in den Armen. Allein schon vom, müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen, ich hatte Muskelkater in den Armen
und Schultern nur vom Bewegen der Arme beim Rennen. Also so wenig wurden die benutzt, um sich da
renntechnisch zu bewegen. In den Armen, nicht in den Beinen, in den Armen. Danach habe ich 3,1
Kilometer mal getestet, wie gut das funktioniert. Und das ging erstaunlich gut, nur dass ich mega
Muskelkater in den Beinen, in den Waden, in den Oberschenkeln hatte. Und jetzt ist es sogar so,
und das ist das, was mich auch echt schon ein bisschen motiviert hat, ich habe jetzt,
ich habe mir da auch so eine Magnesiumpille noch eingeschmissen, dass es wieder schneller
weg geht. Und jetzt, wo ich gestern gerannt bin, ich habe heute nichts mehr. Also ich habe keinen
Muskelkater in den Beinen. Ich habe heute gemerkt, beim Berg hoch, Berg runter wandern, habe ich schon
gemerkt, dass so die Beine ein bisschen, sagen wir mal, ein bisschen angestrengter,
erschöpfter sind, weil ich gestern da meine 50 Minuten gerannt bin. Das habe ich heute schon
gemerkt noch, aber es ging. Und ich denke mal, morgen ist das dann wieder weg und dann kann ich
wieder eine Runde rennen. Aber ansonsten, das geht erstaunlich gut und Muskelkater ist jetzt auch
keiner mehr da. Da sieht man mal, wie schnell das geht, wenn man es einfach mal macht. Aber ob ich
das jetzt auf lange Sicht durchhalte? Mal gucken, mal gucken. Also solange mich die Sache an sich
motiviert, ist ja gut. Da gibt es keine Frage, da habe ich ja sogar Bock morgens drauf, dann da eine
Runde zu rennen. Also die eineinhalb, zwei Stunden über die Hügel hier im Umland täglich laufen,
das mache ich schon länger. Das mache ich schon seit vor Corona. Seit Corona aber so wirklich
regelmäßig. Seit Corona mache ich das echt jeden Tag, mindestens eineinhalb Stunden. Und das hat
schon seinen Grund, warum ich da 18 Kilo in der Zeit abgenommen habe, wo andere Leute in Corona
18 Kilo drauf geklickt haben. Und die Runde joggen hier, das mache ich jetzt erst seit ungefähr einer
Woche. Drei Stunden, gar so krass ist das ja heute noch nicht. Wobei man sagen muss, die haben das,
ich habe mir so eine Garmin Fitness Tracker Uhr gekauft. Ist schon sehr praktisch, gerade weil du
immer deine Pulsschlag-Herzfrequenz hast. Auch ohne Pulsgurt, die misst das wirklich ganz gut am
Handgelenk auch. Und weil du halt auch richtig schön siehst, wie schnell du gerade bist für
einen Kilometer und sowas. Das ist mega nice damit zu laufen. Also sonst hatte ich halt immer das
Problem, ich bin viel zu schnell gelaufen, weil es mir sonst zu lahm vorkam. Aber wenn ich jetzt
da drauf gucke und sehe schon, ich habe nach dem Losrennen einen Puls von 160, dann denke ich mir,
das kannst du nicht die ganze Runde so machen. Mach mal ein bisschen langsam. Und dann sieht man
so, dass es sich halt so ungefähr auf 8,30 bis 9 Minuten einpendelt, wenn ich anfange den Kilometer
und dann geht es halt runter so auf 8,15, 8,20. Sodass es dann im Endeffekt im Durchschnitt 8,24,
8 Minuten 24 für Kilometer sind. Kannst du dadurch besser schlafen? Das ist schwer zu sagen. Ich würde
schon sagen ja. Ich würde schon sagen ja, aber es ist jetzt kein Riesenunterschied. Ich konnte
eigentlich schon, also ich habe immer so Phasen, was das angeht. In der Regel kann ich eigentlich
ganz gut pennen und dann halt auch schnell. Was weiß ich, wenn die Katze nachts irgendwie mal an
der Tür kratzt, weil sie rein will, dann denke ich mir, okay guter Zeitpunkt jetzt mal aufs Klo zu
gehen. Dann gehe ich aufs Klo, gehe ins Bett und fünf Minuten später penne ich wieder, so nach dem
Motto. Aber ich habe auch Phasen, da kann ich nicht gut schlafen. Unabhängig davon, es ist zu
warm im Schlafzimmer und es ist Sommer und so, ja das ist klar. Aber das liegt glaube ich daran,
dass ich mir was doofes angewöhnt habe. Nämlich, dass ich nur noch mit Smartphone eingeschaltet
penne. Also ich mache immer irgendeinen Stream an oder irgendwelche YouTube Lists oder sowas. Ich
habe dann zwar schon Videos laufen, wo keiner rumschreit. Ich gucke mir jetzt nicht irgendwelche
abgetretenen Let's Player an, die alle furztlang super funny rumschreien müssen, weil nur wenn
es laut schreit, ist es lustig. Ich gucke mir dann schon irgendwelche Sachen an, wo ich gut
bei abschalten kann. Aber ich glaube, es ist keine so gute Idee, dass ich mich daran gewöhnt habe,
dass ich nur noch gescheit pennen kann, wenn irgendwas im Hintergrund dudelt. Weil das Problem
ist, das hört sich jetzt ja eigentlich gut an. Du kannst pennen, wenn was im Hintergrund läuft.
Naja, ich würde aber sagen, dass man trotzdem schlechter schläft. Also ich kann zwar nur noch
gescheit pennen, wenn was im Hintergrund läuft. Aber ich glaube, man schläft insgesamt trotzdem
schlechter, wenn was im Hintergrund läuft, als wenn einfach Schicht im Schacht Ruhe ist und man
so pennen kann. Aber ich habe mich daran so gewöhnt mittlerweile, weil ich halt immer abends im
Bett noch ein bisschen Twitch gucke oder irgendwelche YouTube-Sachen oder irgendwelche
YouTube-Playlists anmache. Ich kann nicht mehr pennen so und das ist halt echt so ein bisschen
ein kleines Problem, was ich habe in der Richtung. ASMR zum Einschlafen beste. Du wirst lachen. Ich
gucke die ein oder anderen ASMR-Videos tatsächlich aber ganz gerne, auch hier vorm Rechner. Aber ich
mag das nicht im Bett auf dem Handy zum Pennen. Ich weiß nicht, das ist merkwürdig. Wenn ich mir
die Sachen anhöre... Na, ear-licking-Mouth-Sounds, das ist nicht so unbedingt meins. Also wenn ich
mir die Sachen hier vorm Rechner anhöre oder so, da werde ich übelst müde und könnte gleich pennen
gehen, so nach dem Motto. Aber im Bett zum Einschlafen mag ich keine ASMR-Videos, weil ich bei
denen immer nicht weiß, wann sie fertig sind. Klingt blöd, weil ASMR... Die sind ja oftmals mega
leise und dann knistert mal wieder was, dann sagt mal wieder einer was leise, dann ist mal wieder
eine halbe Minute wurde das Gefühl, dass da kommt nix. Und durch dieses... Es ist eine halbe Minute
nix zu hören und dann hört man wieder leise was. Das macht mich dann wieder wach. Deswegen gucke
ich viel lieber zum Pennen irgendwelche Themen, die mich am Rande interessieren, die ich anfangen
kann zu gucken, während ich noch wach bin und dann dabei einschlafe. Ich gucke beispielsweise
mega gerne solche Videos irgendwie... Das größte schwarze Loch im Universum wurde entdeckt oder...
Das Alter des Universums. Solche Sachen gucke ich gerne, kann man wunderbar im Hintergrund
laufen lassen. Gibt's ja auch jede Menge Channels, die das alles ohne rumzuschreien machen. Das
gucke ich gerne. Ich gucke sehr gerne irgendwelche Fantasy-Lore-Videos zum Einschlafen. Sei es World
of Warcraft-Lore, obwohl mich das überhaupt nicht interessiert, spiele ich nicht. Dungeons
and Dragons-Lore-Videos, obwohl mich Lores in game auch normales nicht großartig interessiert. Aber
das ist wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen wie so Gute-Nacht-Geschichten mäßig. Da höre ich mir
irgendein Video an, so Hintergrundgeschichte von irgendeinem Fantasy-Charakter und sowas.
Juckt mich null, aber ist wunderbar zum Abschalten. Und es labert einer immer recht monoton die ganze
Zeit. Das ist das, wobei ich gut pennen kann. Welche Gabel hast du? Ich habe eine Forerunner...
Ich glaube 245. Ja, ich glaube... Ah Gott! Das sieht danach aus. Ja, das ist die, glaube ich.
Ja, ja, ja. Das ist die. Ich habe die hier gerade nicht liegen, aber das ist die. Die gucke ich
tatsächlich gerne, aber die kann ich nicht zum Einschlafen gucken, weil da wird halt auch manchmal
ein bisschen Krach gemacht. Die lässt sich super mit meiner Wander-App koppeln. Da kann ich... Die
Kurse werden gesynct und die Touren werden zurück in die Wander-App gesynct. Eigentlich richtig,
nice. Also die Uhr hat... Und der eigentliche Grund, warum ich mir die Uhr gekauft habe,
war die Navigationsfunktion. Ich habe mir die Uhr gar nicht als Motivation gekauft. Gab es
jetzt eigentlich das Update? Achso, ja, die ist immer noch kacke. Also ich habe mir die Uhr gar
nicht gekauft, weil ich mir gedacht habe, super Motivation, um noch ein bisschen mehr Sport zu
machen. Was es jetzt im Endeffekt ist, aber Komoot als Wander-App. Aber der Grund, warum ich mir die
gekauft habe, ist, weil ich mir gedacht habe, das ist eine super Sache zur Navigation, weil ich laufe
auch mal ganz gerne. Also ich plane dann in der Wander-App irgendeine Runde und ich laufe auch
mal ganz gerne Runden, wo ich halt noch nicht hundertmal gelaufen bin. Und eine Sache, die mich
halt immer mega nervt, ist, wenn du irgendwo langläufst, wo du dir nicht ganz sicher bist,
wo es lang geht. Wenn du dann läufst, da hast du links und rechts noch deine Walking-Wanderstöcke,
wobei ich habe so Walking-Stöcke. Ich habe keine, nicht so diese Tracking-Stöcke, wie man das kennt,
sondern solche Nordic-Walking-Stöcke. Wenn du links und rechts so einen Stock hast und dann
aufs Handy gucken musst, wenn du wissen willst, ob du noch auf dem richtigen Weg bist, ist doof.
Die Wander-App, die sagt zwar an, so jetzt hier in 300 Meter rechts, aber auch nicht immer und
nicht immer ganz klar, was gemeint ist. Und du musst dann öfters mal, während du gerade am
Wandern bist, gucken, dass du richtig bis Handy rausholen, Bildschirm anmachen, auf die Wander-App
gucken. Das ist nervig. Das war der eigentliche Grund, warum ich mir die Uhr gekauft habe,
weil ich mir dort den Weg anzeigen lassen kann. Zwar ohne Karten, ohne alles, aber es reicht ja.
Die Uhr hat GPS und du siehst halt genau, ob du auf dem roten Weg noch bist oder nicht. Seitdem
ich mir die gekauft habe, finde ich das auch sehr motivierend, Stats über die eigenen Aktivitäten zu
sehen. Deswegen finde ich, ist das wirklich großer Motivationsfaktor nochmal zusätzlich,
wenn man das ordentlich tracken kann. Das Gute an Wander-Apps sind im Vergleich zu Google Maps,
gar nicht so sehr das wirklich viel bessere Kartenmaterial oder so. Wahrscheinlich ist es
eh mehr oder weniger das Gleiche. Die Routenplanung zu wandern ist oftmals besser, aber du hast halt
viele Möglichkeiten zu gucken, okay, was sagen die Leute über diese Strecke und sowas. Das ist halt
sehr praktisch. Also was liegt auf der Strecke, was man sich gerne angucken sollte und so. Das
ist praktisch. Also ich plane die Routen oftmals anhand der Punkte, die die anderen auf der Map
eingetragen haben und da guckst du rein und denkst, oh das sieht nett aus, da können wir langlaufen.
Außerdem weißt du dann halt auch genau, wie lang ist das und wie lange braucht man zu Fuß und so.
Also gerade zu Fuß die Routenplanung von Google Maps ist nicht so geil. So durch den Wald und so.
Wie lange hält der Akku von der Uhr? Ich würde sagen so vier, fünf Tage. Fünf Tage. Also auf
jeden Fall länger als bei den fetten Smartwatches, die es so gibt, die den Tag halten. Also ich glaube
offiziell sagen sie sieben Tage, aber das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert. Also ich habe sie bisher
eigentlich immer nach zwei Tagen aufgeladen, aber nicht, weil sie leer war. Da war es irgendwie
auf 70 Prozent oder so, sondern einfach, weil sie halt neben dem USB-Anschluss lag. So Leute,
jetzt gehe ich pennen. Wir sehen uns morgen früh 8.30 Uhr oder 9 Uhr, so in dem Dreh, zum Aufwachen
streamen und dann bin ich vorher schon mal eine Runde gerannt. Kann ich euch berichten, wie es
lief. Wir sehen uns. Bis dann. Macht's gut. See you.